[inaudible] ladies and gentlemen,
come on with your bad self.
What are you missing out of your life folks?
What are you missing out of your life?
You're missing lumosity.com get your fucking brain in order.
Stop playing angry birds or keep playing angry birds,
but essentially know that you're wasting your time.
Whereas you could be playing games that are actually good for your dome.
Uh,
that's what Lumosity is.
The Masa is problem solving games that are scientifically designed and based on
like your needs.
If you go to lumosity.com they give you a bunch of different options to fill
out.
Click the get started button now and get started now button.
You enter in your information and then you start asking it a or it starts asking
you like what specific things you want to work on?
Do you want to work on memory?
Do you want to work on,
you know,
all,
all sorts of different,
let's try and get me to sign in here.
No one's trying to do that.
We,
monster.com forward slash show.
Why is it doing something weird or that it didn't do before?
Um,
anyway,
scientifically designed to challenge your brain and do it like,
like a game.
So it makes it fun.
Um,
I enjoy playing the games only takes a few minutes a day and over time you can
actually track your progress online and compare yourself to others if you're one
of those mother fuckers that I was to compare yourself to others.
Like I,
there was this one guy,
I remember this documentary about what the smartest man in the world and he
worked as a bouncer in a bar in long island and I'm like,
ah,
no you're not okay.
You're not because you work as a bouncer in a bar in La and you're just not the
fucking smartest guy in the world.
And he was this guy who was giving rambling on and on and he was super verbose
and using a lot of big words and going on about,
you know,
he's the first guy ever that's come come the closest to ultimate meaning to
remember that guy,
big fat face dummy.
I thought he was just very,
very cold out,
convinced why?
Because he got a good number on a Mensa test,
you know,
so he's,
he's good at figuring out how to count up numbers socially.
He's a mess.
Uh,
unable to see how goofy he sounds saying he's the smartest man in the world.
No self deprecating skills.
Thinks he's a bad ass.
Cause he was a bouncer at a bar in long island and think it's like some sort of
a run UNESCO cataract character,
you know,
just a rebel.
He's a,
he's a bouncer,
but he's the smartest man in the world.
Now you're not dead.
But if you were smartest man in the world,
you would realize being a bouncer at a fucking bar in long island sucks a fat
deck and you'd get a better job.
Dummy.
That job's dumb.
Not The answer.
Now,
I was a security guard at one point in time.
I'm not above,
I'm talking,
don't get me wrong,
but you can't claim smartest guy in the world.
And that's where you found yourself at 40 so shut your hole and go to Lumosity.
Who?
lumosity.com/joe.
That's lumosity.com/joe Click the start training button and then start playing
your very first game,
lumosity.com/joe it's very interesting.
Uh,
it's,
it's a fun way to do things that,
you know,
Nord Nerilee would feel just like games,
but these games actually are scientifically designed through something called
neuroplasticity,
which I'm too stupid to understand.
Uh,
you can even play them from your iPhone,
iPad with a free Lumosity APP.
So Lumosity caught.com forward slash Joe,
go check it out.
Freaks.
We're also brought to you by on it.com that's o n n I t on it is a human
optimization website.
And what we sell is everything that we find that benefits you or whether it's
physically,
whether through through strength and conditioning equipment or exercise DVDs,
or whether it's nutritionally through things like the new warrior bar that we
just started selling,
which is made out of organic buffalo meat and cranberries.
It's fucking delicious.
14 grams of protein,
no antibiotics,
no added hormones,
gluten free,
no nitrates.
It's a fucking yummy thing that you can eat and you don't have to feel bad about
eating it because it's actually good for you.
140 calories,
four grams of fat per two ounce serving and 14 grams of protein from lean meat.
It's the bomb diggity sons and daughters.
Um,
and then other than that,
we sell just the best shit that we can find,
whether it's hemp protein powder or whether it's a this earth grown nutrient
supplement that we've just recently started packing,
which is fantastic.
It's filled with all sorts of really healthy things for your body.
Antioxidants,
green blends with full of micro nutrients,
things like Spirulina and Alfalfa.
Um,
if you go to the website and read it at any of the products that we sell,
there's a detailed explanation of what the ingredients are,
why we chose them,
what they do,
what the science on them is.
There's every supplement we have has referenced scientific papers that are
written about the individual ingredients and of course Alpha brain by itself,
which is a combination of already proven ingredients that we put together to try
to form some sort of as synergistic effect and we had positive results through a
double blind placebo trial,
the results of which are available and on.com and there's also a new much larger
study that's going on,
ongoing a hundred percent money back guarantee on all supplements as well.
You have a 90 pill,
30 day or a 30 pill,
90 day rather,
30 pill,
90 day,
hundred percent money back guarantee.
You don't even have to return the product to say it sucks and you get your money
back.
I was trying to rip you off.
We're just trying to sell you awesome shit.
Go to [inaudible] dot com [inaudible] and it used the Codeword Rogan and save
10% off any and all supplements.
Get on it.
Dirty freaks.
Honey,
honey is here.
Why fuck around young Brian,
cue the music
experience
what you dirty.
We had an issue.
We had a little,
a little sound issue.
We wanted to make sure that everything was clean and smooth.
Since you guys are here and this is sound is a very important part of what you
do.
I don't have to tell you this,
it is a key to your lifestyle.
So,
uh,
hey,
what's up fuckers?
What are you doing?
We're,
you know,
we're chilling.
We're so excited to be in California.
Yeah.
What happened?
Nashville lost its charm.
Well,
oh well knowing when we left,
let's put it that way.
Was it really?
Yeah,
it was snowing and it's really interesting because the whole city really shuts
down like at like schools close and I'm talking like a mile dusting,
just like
they just told you already.
It was like rain out here.
Right here.
People Freak out.
But worse though,
right?
The freak out.
Do you mean like Joe?
Yeah.
Joey was he Thompson?
Guerra.
Joey was with,
I forget who he was with in um,
Oregon.
They were up in Oregon doing shows and it a freak snowstorm blanketed the city
and then it got icy rain below it.
Yeah.
So it was snow on top of icy rain.
It was just the whole city just shut down.
I mean,
if,
if they don't have the,
you know,
uh,
the salt trucks and all that stuff,
and if people don't know how to drive it,
they really shouldn't,
you know?
But it's really interesting.
I mean,
they,
they closed school for like three days and you know,
the roads were really fine.
Right.
It's just,
it was amazing.
What do you guys think about Nashville?
Has the charm worn off?
Are you bored with it?
Already?
Talk.
And we came back the other night.
We got,
got into la yesterday and walked into this bar and all these people that I knew
were there and all these friends and it just felt good man.
And there's friends.
There's really it.
Nashville is interesting because when you first get there,
it's such an open community and people welcome you in and everyone's sweetened.
You have friends and all of a sudden you're,
you,
you go out to the barn,
you know people.
But there's a difference when you see people you've been with for eight years,
10 years,
it just feels right.
Good.
Right,
right.
So coming back,
I don't know.
Beautiful.
They're kind of wistful.
Do you guys,
do you,
do you mess the,
like the largeness of the city or is it the people,
the attitude like Di did you feel different?
Like a different vibe?
I've never lived in that bro.
Yeah,
but did you get like a different vibe from the people?
I mean the,
the d well first of all,
I mean,
you can drive around the whole city in like 15 minutes.
it's just,
you're,
the days feel longer because you're not stuck in your car trying to get here to
there like you do in La.
It doesn't,
you know what I mean?
It's you just sort of like,
everything is really accessible,
which is,
which was great because as far as our productivity and working on the record,
which is kind of why we went there,
um,
to write and have all this space,
Richard and then we just kept,
we still not done with do it there.
We keep coming back here to work on.
Yeah,
it's true.
So it's really interesting,
like how,
you know there's,
there's some,
there's a number of reasons why,
you know,
it's,
it's a much more affordable town and all that stuff,
but,
but when you,
when I come to California now,
I really feel like,
like this intense energy,
like you're like vibrating.
It's so exciting.
I just,
you know,
you kind of feel like,
it's like this shock of you.
You're just awake
and there's all this stuff happening.
There's so many,
so many fucking people and Nashville's great.
It's just like really chill,
you know?
Good.
Sometimes when you have it for a long time,
you kind of get a little stir crazy.
It just doesn't look good to look my crazy eyes.
The diversity here,
it's a completely different game in terms of that there,
there's this really interesting going on of like Bible belt conservatism and
freaky people.
You know,
there's kind of different 50 people area,
but that's spreading quirky.
People are spreading.
We're windows.
It's more fun to be a Weirdo.
That Bible Belles Shit.
Once he catch a few of them fucking kids doing weird shit.
We're supposed to be all high Falutin that's kind of game over there.
Yeah,
it's game over.
They start losing credibility.
I definitely feel a little more self aware in Nashville as far as like my,
you know,
my fucking potty mouth and my,
just being loud and loud because there's a lot more,
I feel like [inaudible] liquored up.
You picked it up.
I think people are a little more reserved.
Of course.
Yeah.
I genuinely really enjoy playing there.
I think it's one of my favorite places.
I love the people there.
I love the small town thing about it too.
I just think people are super friendly there,
but I wonder if I would go crazy if I lived there.
The by the Bible belt thing would probably can avoid it and it's honestly,
it's,
it seems fairly segregated.
It's like you just don't walk down that street.
That's hilarious.
Yeah,
that's true.
Amazing.
People believe in dinosaurs.
They're street.
Not so much.
Somebody tweeted me something with some woman,
you know,
they were just talking about the dinosaurs must've probably drown and she wasn't
trolling,
uh,
that,
that Noah didn't have room for them on the Ark,
so they probably won't drown.
He knows our Facebook page and someone,
someone sent me a tweet,
can you believe this silly bitch?
And it was a two or Facebook page because it was so ridiculous that random
people that didn't even know her.
We're going to her Facebook page and be like,
pitch,
are you fucking crazy?
Dinosaurs drowned.
It's fucking Russell Kroll's fault.
He decided to do this God damn Noah movie.
And the whole thing gets stirred up again.
No,
he's dead.
It's a Darren our foam long ski,
whenever his name was [inaudible] [inaudible] who is a apparently bad
motherfucker.
He's done a lot of pretty bad ass movies,
right?
Yeah.
But what else has he done?
Oh God.
Did he do gladiator?
I don't know who that is.
Have you seen the ads for Noah?
Nope.
Which page?
Damn it.
That's exciting.
And I would love to give him a French braid,
which you really like.
Rocket Jamaica style up.
Just checking in once.
He's like the Denzel
of white people kind of does spray since all the,
never got fat.
Awesome
speech.
A story.
You'll love this movie.
You know,
they,
I don't,
you know,
fantasy kind of like Lord of the rings.
I'm so grateful,
Lord of the Rings.
I'm like,
God,
I really enjoyed Lord of the rings too.
I love fantasy movies.
They're fun.
I had high hopes for the new code and movie didn't really work out.
It's terrible shit.
But it was good.
Like halfway into it I was like,
it's still pretty good.
And then the new Conan is the guy from game of Thrones who played,
um,
the barbarian dude was banging Khaleesi
I bet that dude,
he's a very nice guy,
too.
Big giant handsome bastard.
And uh,
he was the perfect Conan Lenny Kravitz daughter or something.
Could they or no,
that'll work.
That'll,
that'll last.
Sorry.
Wait to be optimist.
He's awesome.
I mean,
he's just too handsome to be running around.
They're married to anybody.
But,
uh,
the,
the movie was like,
it held promise,
you know,
it looked like it was going to be good,
but like all these fucking movies and eventually falls apart unfortunately.
But I gave it a shot.
I don't,
didn't remember that coming out.
Did it get good reviews or it did dog shit reviews wasn't that good.
But he's the perfect Connie on.
If they had a good writer,
like if you got James Cameron involved and he,
you know,
put together like some Avatar type tone and movie,
it would be the shit.
Cause the guys,
the perfect coin he got can act as ass off.
He's good.
You know,
he really would have been Conan,
but they gave him a dog shit movie.
That's a bummer.
It is.
And you can't turn that role.
It's like,
it's a huge role.
You know,
you can't turn it down and then everything else falls through.
Well nobody remembers anyway.
You guys didn't remember it.
Nobody remembers.
I think making movies must be hard.
Uh,
fuck.
So yeah,
you do it at home.
There's so many people involved.
There's too many people.
The beautiful thing about what you guys do is who do you,
you know,
you fucking talk amongst yourselves.
You know,
you say you want more of this,
and he says he wants more of that and together you find some sort of a happy
medium and you create your shit.
But could you imagine if you had a bunch of money people?
Well,
I'm not saying it's easy at all,
but different of less intervention.
Then you making a movie,
man,
you got hundreds of people that have their say.
You have so many people that you have.
You have to consider what kind of movie you're making.
If you're making an independent movie,
right?
Even then you guys still have a deal with 15 people.
Some actor wants to do a fucking monologue in the middle of the scene.
You're like,
probably this is not the part.
The part is not,
it doesn't do a monologue,
man.
I'll do it.
If I could do a monologue here.
Well,
this is a different movie.
Then the guys deaf,
he can't talk.
He can be
like the end psych.
Here's what I heard.
This was always about making choices.
Choice.
It's,
it's just when you deal with a lot of people,
it's very difficult to have a creative vision that goes through.
Do you guys have any,
like,
do you,
does your manager ever say,
look,
you need more,
more jokes or more songs about this or more songs about that had stuff like that
before and gross.
Yeah.
Well,
I mean at the end of the day it's like if you have,
we really
too difficult to work with like that.
We don't right now we don't have a manager right now.
Maybe that's what happened.
Then I may your manager and I'll tell him what was it I had done?
Me Your agent or your manager,
can you remember an agent?
Yeah.
And that was an amicable thing,
but just,
I don't know what kind of like the tiger,
I don't like you.
You don't like me.
Let's get out of here.
But people say Amazon
divorce is like,
well,
it's amicable.
Who?
No,
it's not amicable.
You got so sick of each other that you went to court.
Okay.
Don't tell me to amicable like each other's still as human beings.
But that shit ain't amicable.
You don't live together anymore.
You don't fuck,
you guys got divorced
[inaudible] I heard a new term for that today though.
Cause I was reading about the Gwyneth Paltrow and Chris Martin.
It just came up.
I wasn't looking for it.
It's an unconscious wait,
wait,
conscious on partnering,
partnering,
Janet,
Gwyneth Paltrow,
splitting up with her man.
Just partnering.
So sad.
I'm a fucking romantic day.
I bet you are.
I believe it.
And we'll loosen this other one would love,
Hey,
I'm just saying he wants to live with Paltrow four though or that guy from
Coldplay.
I'm sure he's a fucking whiny vagina to Jesus Christ.
I mean anybody who writes and sings those songs,
beautiful songs as they may be.
Why are you not like tears that a single and how come your songs aren't about
celebrating the fact that you're a fucking rockstar?
How come your songs aren't celebrating the fact that
it truly is?
Dude,
so celebration,
you're unbelievable.
Kool and the gang knew how to do it.
Stevie wonder knew how to do it.
But most people,
I bet most of the bands
that you listened to,
right?
Depressing shit a long time.
Is that easier?
It's just easy to access that.
So or easier.
Is it easier also to not be like,
like a sort of a superficial dommy who's singing about happiness?
Like if you sing about moodiness,
like you're automatically deep and meaningful.
Yeah,
Bro.
Like I remember that movie.
21 grams.
You remember that movie recently?
It's so sad.
And I made a decision after I saw that movie.
I said,
never again will I go see a movie that's trying to make me sad.
Like I don't,
I don't buy the idea that it's deep because it makes you feel like shit.
I don't buy it.
I know what you're doing.
You're,
you're,
it's,
this is a game here.
Everything falls apart.
Everything goes to shit at the end.
You feel all this loss and then I,
I know what you did.
You guys fucked me.
You pretended that you were doing something deep.
You're not,
you're just doing something depressing,
depressing and deeper.
Not the same goddamn thing
it's on,
on.
Um,
I recently saw that movie.
Was it the lone ranger?
Wait,
no,
no.
India.
Not the lone ranger.
The uh,
the one with Mark Wahlberg.
Oh my God.
I'm so sorry.
The lone soldier.
Lone survivor.
Survivor.
God,
Samsonite.
Um,
it was,
but,
but that was based off of a true story and actually has some relevance as far as
the reality that we live in right now.
Yeah,
definitely.
But that,
that is a little bit different.
That's not necessarily like,
Hey,
I'm making this movie to fuck you up.
Yeah.
But it really fucked me up.
I had to go drive around for like 20 minutes after I left the movie theater.
And it was um,
I mean,
did you see it?
I watched part of it.
Um,
those movies kind of bummed me out.
Yeah.
Marcus Luttrell is a guy I've met at the UFC a few times.
Okay.
Who's the,
the story?
The story's based on,
he's actually in the movie.
Had a part.
He did.
Yeah.
But he,
um,
you know his real story.
You've met him.
Yeah.
I have a real hard time.
I'm watching dramatizations with Marky mark and someone else play in these guys.
I know it was awesome and I'm not putting him down.
I love Mark Wahlberg.
I'm a huge fan.
I thought he was great in that movie with the Rock.
He's fucking great kids.
A great actor.
It's not that.
It's just,
I know he's Marky mark teglar though.
He wouldn't.
Yeah,
whoever he is,
he's Mark Wahlberg.
I know he's Mark Walberg and I know who the guy is.
I know that guy.
Marcus Luttrell is a real person.
So when I'm watching a recreation it's,
it's weird,
but I can't separate myself from the art.
I enjoy them much more in works of fiction that I do and break recreation's.
I never enjoy recreation's cause I'm always like that and fucking happen like
that.
That's probably bullshit.
He's pumped about titanic is what you're saying.
Well titanic is different because it had Leonardo and Kate and the chemistry
there just went great
dining ramp and the young man with passion poetry and it's hard to know.
It's just,
I think,
I don't like recreation's.
You know,
I just,
I know it's too much fuckery involved in the creation of those things,
but kind of like a frozen guy.
I love frozen.
I saw it twice.
You come over my house at any point in time when you here,
they'll start saying it.
Robert had they jump up on the couch and start singing.
That's amazing.
Little girls love princesses,
man.
There's nothing you can do about that.
There's this rapper that has the second best song,
but he's like,
man,
I could have had the number one song if it wasn't because of the frozen
soundtrack.
Can you imagine that?
He just loses a good fucking movie man for little kids.
It's not a good movie for adults,
but as an adult you can enjoy it.
Like I find that there's a lot of these movies that they,
they're made for little kids.
Yeah.
But do a really good job and you can actually sit and enjoy the movie with your
kids.
Like I saw the bodies movie,
the Lego movies
by yourself.
Did you?
Not Easy.
They're,
yeah.
But yeah,
it did.
It was a good move.
And it brought me up.
I felt like I was walking out with a whole bunch of friends.
I saw Mr Peabody the in the wayback machine this weekend.
Whenever the fuck it's called,
it's a really good,
first of all,
the animation is fucking amazing.
The dog,
the dog made a tablet.
It's fucking bad ass.
It's fine.
Yeah.
It's interesting.
It's fun.
You know,
and it's,
it's also like the,
just what they can do with animation now when they are operating the time
machine,
you're like,
God damn,
they make shit look beautiful.
You don't make Scooby doo look like dog shit.
You know,
you stop and look at the kind of like,
this is Mr Peabody.
Really?
This was good.
Yeah,
no,
you got to see the,
uh,
the time machine series when he actually uses the time machine.
You've got to find,
look for it and find a video that when,
when they operate the time machine,
you see the graphics involved.
It's like a whole,
my God,
these kids today,
they're so spoiled.
Yeah,
it's true.
It's true.
I up,
I was a big fan of pop was great,
came out,
but that's depressing as fuck.
That guy's essentially suicidal.
No Dash.
It's good to have
darkness for kids.
You have to get a little introduction in reality.
I am.
I am,
because I'll be honest with you,
I'm not,
I'm not going to get into details,
but like I had a real solid shattering of my idealism in my adulthood that was
like really intense.
And it's,
it's interesting when you sort of,
I mean,
just could have prepared you for that.
Well,
yeah.
Fuck yeah.
No,
I'm not.
I'm kind of fucking around,
but I'm not fucking around,
but,
but I'm serious as far as like,
you know,
the princess reality for little kids,
if you,
if you sort of had this like fairy tale,
right?
It's just a,
and not in an aggressive way.
Um,
so my ex boyfriend wrote this book that is actually,
it's a children's book.
It's called Kate's first mate.
Um,
and it's about relationships,
but it's written as a children's book and it's actually really amazing.
And he sells it,
um,
like hotcakes and all these like kind of little hipster stores in California.
And,
um,
it's published.
And it's a really interesting look at,
um,
you know,
choose choosing a partner for,
when you're a kid and just sort of,
rather than like prince charming comes in on a white horse,
you know,
it's just sort of has this really great way to kind of just give a small
introduction to kids about,
you know,
reality.
And sometimes it doesn't work out and you go through the storm and then you come
out,
you know,
captaining the ship with euro,
with your partner.
You
know what's interesting man?
Man,
you know,
man.
Yeah,
Bro.
People,
friends,
Babe.
What's interesting friends is how,
um,
how much they're trying to take when they take old stories and they pull all the
teeth out of them.
Like it's,
it's really kind of fascinating,
like the big bad wolf or any of these stories like there,
there's this,
uh,
this trend.
What is this ad?
There's a lot of people that think that Disney's frozen.
It's teaching kids to be in like gay,
like Disney's gay propaganda.
Um,
excellent.
And Idiots.
Why was it,
what's gay about frozen?
They,
they said that the,
the main character,
uh,
with the other girl,
I never saw it so I don't know.
But the main character?
Yeah,
sister that they're gay.
Yeah.
Oh my God.
Just don't even click on that.
And about beastiality too because of the,
the animals were her friends.
Oh,
teaching kids about these.
What about your pet on the podcast?
I'd like to see that one.
Not even know where the podcast is.
Fuck all these fucking dummies.
God dammit.
I don't remember what we're talking about.
How they took the old
days.
Take all these stories like the big bad wolf and they little or little red
riding hood and they kinda like dress it down.
They take away all the violence and scariness out of it.
And you get a version of like for kitchens like Rapunzel.
Here's a perfect example.
Think it was scary.
Like real ones were really starting,
which she,
she took her puzzle,
cut her hair off and pretended that the guy was climbing your hair.
And then pushed him off and he got blinded.
That's the original story.
Fell into a briar Bush and his eyes got fucking gouged out.
If you read the original one,
you're like,
Whoa,
brothers Grimm.
Yeah.
All that stuff is sticking out a dead chicken bone.
They think it's their finger.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Well,
and the wolf,
eight Little Red Riding Hood and the grandmother,
I mean,
she died in the original one.
The,
in the original,
she was eaten by the wolf and then somehow or another,
the hunter cut her out of the wolf or something like that.
No.
What I do remember that.
Yeah,
the grandma and her,
they're both,
okay.
I caught him out and bring it back to real town.
You know,
this is what's really happening.
Well,
it's just weird how,
you know,
they try to like slowly but surely over time take the teeth out of a lot of
those things.
It's like if you go back and watch cartoons from,
like when I was a kid,
they were all about violence.
Yeah.
Cartoons were all about anvils falling on people's heads and explosions,
spinning a duck's beak around a circle.
Yeah.
But then you have some really terrible things that there's never one thing,
one reason to blame for when there's like a school shooting or something like
that.
But then that is the basis of changing the whole,
you know,
viewing,
um,
demographic and you know,
watering it down so it's not as violent.
Like,
you know,
I don't,
I don't really have an opinion on it,
but,
but that's where it comes from.
I don't know if there's a direct correlation between viewing violence and
enacting violence.
I'm really not sure if there is,
nor my sure if it's ever been proven.
Because you see more violence now than ever.
And I would say that's probably the least violent time we've ever existed in a
on earth.
But I know that kids have done shit they saw in commercials or cartoons.
Rather.
My cousin,
Mikey hit his brother over the head with a frying pan because they thought it
was going to turn into another shape
and cracked him over the head.
Turn to the shape of a frying pan.
You fucking walked up to his little brother Room Bong and hear screaming and the
dad beat the shit out of him.
It was craziness.
It's dark.
It was dark.
How do you come out to the,
okay,
that's fucked up.
That kids always been fucked up.
I avoided him ever since I was like seven when I read,
when I get out of the Catholic school,
I've waited.
My cousin to
I kept,
might not even be my cousin Mikey.
Mikey made it,
actually been his neighbor and now that I think about it,
either way,
not good to hit kids in the head with a frying pan and he learned it from a
television show.
Some cartoon you,
your head is like,
you gotta do that.
Shakes it back.
Nobody ever dies.
But everybody gets blown to fucking smithereens.
I mean all the shit that happened to wile e coyote and you know,
the end,
he would pop his head up and fucking dust would fall off of them and he's fine
that fucker,
but it was all violence.
There's none of that today.
You will never see a kid's show today that has violence in it.
They just don't have it.
Everything's cutesy.
Panda was pretty hardcore raising pussies.
No one shot the panda.
Spanish had been hit with a fucking missile cannon balls in their
cannon balls a little bit,
but no one got hurt,
right?
No,
no.
There was no serious dog.
Humans where feelings.
So feelings are more valuable sometimes,
but at the same time you have this whole world of really fucked up abstract
cartoons and shit,
right?
That is available to kids.
It's not presented to them really.
But if you Google some weird stuff,
you can find anything you want.
You can be a five year old now and probably a year,
a five year old that's Google and your parents are doing a Shitty fucking job
listening to you.
Don't you don't leave five-year-old's in front of a fucking computer.
However,
kids,
I can't,
I have no,
no,
it's a lot than back in the day.
You were saying something.
That was it.
I just feel this is me assuming or guessing that you can get into some weird
stuff too.
You could if you had no oversight,
but you should have oversight when you're five.
You know,
it's like we were talking about when I was,
uh,
when I did a magic show in fisherman's wharf when I was eight.
Why did I do that?
Because nobody was watching me.
It's ridiculous.
Like,
you know,
anybody tells you I was raised correctly.
Uh,
you know,
a point to that and go,
do you think it's an eight year old?
Should be able to just walk down the street and not tell anybody where he's
going?
That's ridiculous.
Like that's not a good move.
That's pretty profound though,
that you were like,
did you take the train walk?
Yeah.
Well I lived in San Francisco.
Yeah,
no,
it was during the day.
I live pretty close to fisherman's wharf.
I noticed that people were doing these,
um,
one person shows on fisherman's wharf.
They had like a little box out and people throw money in it.
So I did a magic show
and it's almost good that no one stopped you.
Right.
You didn't have oversight and you figure your shit out.
Maybe something horrible could have before.
Man Almost got raped by some dude,
but she did a got lucky,
the library and library and saw the guy and yelled,
I was ready to go out this guy's car.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Oh my God.
That was the same age I was.
Um,
I was really in a monsters,
like monster books and stuff like that.
And so I was at the library and the monster section pulling out these books and
this guy came up to me and told me that he had monster books in his car.
And,
uh,
I didn't know any better.
I was only eight years old,
so I was like,
okay,
you got monster books.
I thought it was just a guy with monster bucks.
Go sit in your lap for some monster books.
And as I was walking towards the car,
well as I was walking towards the car,
the library and starts screaming,
you know,
you get away from him.
That guy just got out of prison.
That guy just got out of prison by Jesus Christ.
Yeah.
Apparently he was like a known pedo and they would have to watch him when he
would go to the library cause you'd go scouting around for kids.
Yeah,
I had some weird stuff when I was a kid,
you know,
there was this a older boy who was in the neighborhood and um,
I was a little tomboy.
I'd always be like playing in the backyard,
you know,
like,
I dunno,
like chopping trees,
whatever.
We grew up on an acre.
Um,
and I had this really interesting moment where I was in the backyard and I was
obsessed with fishing.
I love to fish.
I still do.
And um,
and I was talking about it,
you know,
it was really weird,
didn't have a lot of friends and this older boy was like maybe 14 and I was nine
or 10 comes out of the wood line.
It's like,
hey Suzanne,
there's a large mouth bass and the creek.
You've got to come see it right now.
You gotta come see it.
And I remember it like me,
okay,
let me get my shoes.
Like I'm going to,
okay,
I got to go to the house.
And like I think my parents are out and my sisters and I would always like we
were when we were kids,
everybody be running around like playing baseball.
Like there was like a pack of kids and my sisters were home but I didn't know
where they were.
And I ran upstairs to get my shoes and then all of a sudden I had this moment of
uh,
I was totally terrified.
I was just all of a sudden I felt like really weird.
And I,
I went upstairs in my bedroom,
which overlooked the backyard and I watched him and I didn't leave.
I got really scared and um,
and I watched him and I watched him kind of wait around for while and leave.
And like later this kid was like,
like years later it was like blowing up squirrels in his tree house and like it
got like he was hurting like the neighborhood animals and like got into some
serious trouble and he was a violent kid and now as an adult,
like there's,
there's no way,
there was a large amount of bass in the creek.
It was like this tiny little creek.
And I really do,
when I think about it,
I feel like I avoided a really weird situation.
I don't fucking know.
Oh fucker knows.
I mean you might've been the first one that he killed.
It might've been,
the circumstances were right.
You never know.
But I,
I really like it was like,
it's,
it's so funny.
Like I don't remember everything but I will never forget that feeling of like,
like I was just terrified.
I didn't want to go back.
And you never know,
like certain circumstances,
like people are like really close to doing something fucked up and never do it
until a circumstance arises.
That might've been the circumstance that pushed the guy
over the edge.
Well,
the person that blows up animals in their tree house has some serious issues.
He asked me,
well,
anybody who does torture
animals,
that's like one of the first things they look for.
Yeah.
You know when,
when you find out that your son has been nail a squirrel to a board and sticking
sticks up its ass and stuff like that,
like that kid's a monster.
Like you got to,
you got a bunch of bad connections.
Yeah.
And you should take the little fucker fishing.
Take him out in the middle of the ocean.
Yeah.
Sorry it didn't work out.
Sorry Buddy.
Sorry Pal.
I raised a monster.
Take it out.
Take it out to the ocean.
Fishing though.
Efficiencies,
great physicians,
Great Psychos,
band,
Pontoon boat and in Tennessee and that was really fun.
Ted Is,
he's got great bass.
Russians didn't catch a fish,
but man drank a whole bunch of beer.
Got a Sun Tan,
if you can believe that because I'm white is goat cheese.
It's very rare.
So are you guys gonna move back?
What are you gonna do?
Man?
We've got to make some money.
We got to places.
Record.
My basement is an isolation tank in it for in there.
Hey,
did we talk about that thing you didn't tell putting us in that time?
Yeah,
we met crash.
How was the experience?
So we didn't talk about it.
How was it?
It was,
it was awesome.
I uh,
I kind of freaked out at one point.
Did Ya?
Yeah,
because I started to get really,
um,
I was like,
oh my God,
what if a would have crashed,
forgot to close the air open air thing.
And I,
I started to like,
then I was like,
okay,
breathe.
I can't breathe.
And I was like trying to find the door and then I got the water in my eye and I
was like,
you panics.
Is that,
oh yeah,
I lost it.
You panic toad dairy.
It was a real cute,
precious moment I had naked in that tank.
That's hilarious.
Yeah.
The next time relax or you'll be fine.
It's hard.
That's a new experience.
Yeah.
That is not,
uh,
something I'm accustomed to.
That's the thing about it.
It's like,
it's not one of those things you get used to the first time.
And you get better at it.
The like,
my body's so used to it that I get in there and my body goes,
Whoa,
we're in the tank.
And then I just let go.
Like immediately,
like the first when I first started doing,
I'd be like,
I had all this busy work.
Like I'd want to itch something,
something.
Yeah.
But now you can just settle in.
But you can come up with some great ideas in there too.
It's like you never get a chance to be alone with yourself like you do in that
tank.
Have you really want to be a moody depressing fuck and write some shit that's
gonna make people cry?
No thank God.
The spa spot
in a box of block figure things out.
I just think there's no better place for me to figure things out.
Like anytimes I have real problems in my life.
Anytime there's any disputes or any time I'm doing something I don't want to be
doing,
I get in that tank and it sort of provides me with the resources to come up with
the right answers other cause.
Other than that tank.
You don't,
you don't get alone time like that.
You never alone time from your body
and that's where you made it to no,
I don't ever meditate outside the tank.
Yeah.
Except I guess a little bit doing yoga.
I guess a little bit of that.
It's meditation,
but it's Yoga,
you know,
it's the whole thing.
The tank is just the mind,
you know.
But I don't,
I don't fuck around with regular meditation.
To me it's like,
it's like running when you have a car.
I'm like,
I want to get to Vegas.
Um,
probably going to drive,
you know,
it took a lot longer to walk,
like,
just sitting like
this is what oming is.
It's walking to Vegas.
Oh,
I don't know.
I'm into it.
I'm not going to lie.
We try mentality in the clients.
You don't have a tent.
If you get a tank basement and,
and the tank,
it's a tote.
Some next level.
Well,
shit,
Elman is Hank.
I opened,
it.
Sank.
Do I do,
uh,
these breathing exercises in a tank where I've,
I breathe in for one minute and then I breathe out for one minute.
Yeah.
One slow minute breathing in and one slow minute breathing out.
It's really hard that you,
in fact,
actually where Jason Bourne,
you know the first Jason Bourne movies I enjoyed,
but the new one with that fucking Guy Jeremy Renner.
It's too much fake karate going on.
So much shit that the body can't do.
I'm not buying it.
You let us live in our fantasize guys living in the fucking frozen north and his
underwear,
they'd come and get him.
They activate them.
Things wrong with that.
Guys going to get hypothermia.
He's a fucking human jumping off of buildings and ending on people's heads.
No Angle.
Real nothing.
I'm not buying it.
And here's the big one.
Doesn't have sex with anybody.
I know.
That is a bummer.
It's ridiculous.
Don't do that.
Spies of bone and everywhere.
Well,
it's what we're doing here.
We're the pussification of the American male is almost complete.
Our superheroes in even get pussy James Bond fucked everyone.
Okay?
He was from England.
God dammit,
and he fucked everyone.
He'd fucked everyone he drank.
We even know how he takes his fucking Martinis.
Shaken.
Never stirred.
We know how he likes his drugs.
That's,
that's fucking the murderers drug distribution.
He got mad pussy fucked and he had so much pussy.
He had a movie called Octopussy.
I mean,
Jesus fucking Christ.
He's a winner.
Meanwhile,
Jeremy Renner saves the girl who's hotter than the surface,
the fucking sun.
He's hanging out with her all movie long.
Obviously she's enthralled with him and the end of the movie is so symbolic of
the,
the neutering of the American male that even the super bad ass murdering
superstars sit like there on the boat together and they're sitting across from
each other.
Why do you think that on the table?
Did you see maybe I want to know how they got out of that.
There was,
there was a very intense intimate friends have been barely once the credits
roll.
We're going to no,
no,
no.
I didn't see that.
Why couldn't you bone before the credits rolled at all?
I didn't see what you're saying.
I didn't see any bone and going on ever in their future.
No.
It was unspoken,
I think.
Is Dick's broken?
I think in order to be able to flip like that
in real life.
I'm sure it works great,
but that Jeremy Renner in the movie though,
the Jason Warren Guy,
Jason Bourne,
he was the new guy.
He was,
I don't know what I'm talking to another guy,
whatever his fucking name was born,
born with a broken dick.
The guy's kicking everybody's ass and it's,
this girl clearly wants to throw down.
She's like staring at him.
I'm like,
Oh my God,
you're the best.
You saved my life over and over again and you're single.
And I'm saying,
oh,
like what do we fucking around for it and this and he's just standing there
staring at her.
I'm your robot.
I will kill for you,
but I cannot fuck.
He didn't have any romantic attachment to it.
There's no kissing.
There was no hugging a personality thing.
The next Jason Bourne Guy,
whatever his name is,
because it's not his fault.
No,
he's simple.
He's symptomatic of a problem we have in society.
The,
the sexuality of the American male is a dangerous thing.
The neutering of the American male is a lot of people's goals.
Ultimately,
as we move away from our primate warring lifestyle into this transcendental
experience where we pass through the the next dimension and we exist in the
world of information purely without any of the needs of the flesh,
that's what we're moving away from.
That's why people don't want to be Harry.
That's why everybody wants to shave your Bush,
shave everything down back though.
It's like skinnier jeans.
It's not going to last.
When push comes to shove,
I think it's all the same thing.
I think we're moving away from,
from animal instincts and so even in our superheroes,
we want no animal instincts.
He's just a killing martial arts robot who doesn't want to fuck at the end of
it,
he sits down there and there's no threat whatsoever that he only saved all those
people because he wants a fucker because the people that wrote the movie wanted
to widen their audience instead.
Well that's one way of looking at it.
But why would that,
why would that be appealing?
More people watch porn than almost anything on the Internet.
It's some insane amount of bandwidth allocated.
While I try that something Brian's Dad,
sorry Gary.
Go all together.
One,
two,
three.
Sorry.
You're taking it out of context like you always do Brian.
I'm tired of your bullshit.
Just because you're on the internet doesn't mean you have to get back at me for
everything that ever happened.
Yeah,
I dunno.
I Dunno what it is,
but I think there is a move without a tout to moving away from animal instincts.
So I think that was a female empowerment thing going on and that's an animal and
it's take right.
What female empowerment do you think?
Well,
I'm actually,
I'm,
you know,
I'm just going to go with it,
but I was stumbled across some pornography for the first time.
Well,
I was brushing my teeth and I stepped over a sock and went flying forward and my
head hit a nursing civic thing on the laptop.
I'm just going to barrel through this because I thought it was interesting.
It was purely sociological.
Um,
they,
there's like this,
they have all these different texture and you Pete,
Betty be tough.
We don't have to
give me what I need as he comes in.
He goes,
I realize the path that I'm going down.
I feel like I said we'll around and go,
oh no,
no,
no.
Well,
this was the first,
it was like a casting couch scenario.
Right.
But they usually have,
the catechesis isn't just important.
It's,
it's just in general.
Those are Green Simmons favorites.
You bring in a chick and you kind of did basin and make her a,
do whatever you want her to do.
But this flipped it around completely and had this chick completely dominating a
whole group of guys.
There's a whole series of them.
I never seen that before.
That's rare as fuck.
Dude.
You're talking about traveling around though.
It's coming around.
San had this on her phone.
Bookmarks,
bookmark,
double bookmarks.
Put the cloud saved to cloud.
Yes.
Email to be.
And
um,
I,
you know,
I don't know.
I mean for women?
Yeah,
most certainly.
But it's also like think about the fantasies that exists for men.
Really unrealistic fantasies of,
you know,
you order a pizza and the pizza grill comes over and she's wearing a bikini and
next thing you know she's blowing you and your friend,
you know,
and you're both banging her.
Is that realistic?
Is that coming around?
No,
and it doesn't represent real life represents what people want to take a shower.
But I mean if you wanted like porn for women,
porn for women I don't think would even be that.
I think porn for women would probably be far more romantic.
You know,
I spent,
I think also I think there's a difference between the visual aspect,
like what men find appealing,
what women find appealing.
It's like women are into like books like 50 shades of grey type pornography,
but some women are into less visual representations of sexuality.
They don't watch it as much,
you know?
I mean women don't watch it as much as men do to store.
How much stigma is involved with that?
You know,
this,
this website is to rows and weird.
So women stay away from it.
Not necessarily.
They don't want to know about that because mom,
you watch what they want when they were alone,
you were alone actually like real.
Do you know what I mean?
Like if it's not like if someone's actually,
if a woman's actually coming,
that's the best one.
If you ask me as far as like staged porn,
right.
Cause if it's just for the,
for the dude,
there's a lot,
a lot of that too,
right?
It's plays up for the dues
myself up here for
that last thing.
You're fucking,
you're a pointer and you got one call out.
Exactly how it is.
Really did eat her out.
She likes him.
Our farm.
Yeah.
Um,
I see.
I think a lot of women are into porn.
Don't get me wrong,
I'm not delusional.
But I think that there's a lot of,
a lot more women or into a literature,
um,
pornography than men are in a literature.
Pornography.
Like almost no men are into literature,
pornography.
Very rarely.
I'm reading this book called one Kuwaiti for Murakami Book and it's,
it's really interesting.
Once you 84,
what is it about?
It's um,
God,
it's,
it's hard to explain it's fiction.
Um,
and it's,
it's kind of a spin there.
There's a lot of 1984,
um,
kind of like the,
the author is,
you know,
Trulia,
Orwell fan and there's just kind of a lot of nuances as far as like,
um,
this kind of,
I don't want to say apocalyptic,
but,
um,
God,
it's about a lot of confusing things,
but technically it's a romance,
but there's all this sort of,
there's like a kind of like two worlds colliding.
They're sort of like,
like there's two moons in the sky and there's kind of this really interesting
concept.
But,
um,
I,
there's a lot of graphic sexual content and Ben and I were sitting on a plane.
Yeah.
He was like,
Jesus.
Every time I look over there's,
you know,
there's one thing,
the boner going on.
There's like a taught nipple.
Like,
I just catch and that's just read this an 800 page book and every single time I
can glance over it.
It's really funny because I'm not sure.
It's really a great,
it's a really great story.
Um,
and I'll be honest with you,
I'm not,
I'm not one that's like,
yeah,
I need it fucking dirty novel to,
you know,
whatever.
Um,
butter my scone.
But I,
I definitely,
but I definitely like,
we've been traveling a lot,
we've had a few flights shows recently and when I'm reading look at it,
you know,
come on.
That's what I'm saying.
So when I'm reading it in public and I'm sitting on an airplane,
I feel like I pulled a book closer to myself cause I'm just like,
oh my God,
you know what if it's just,
you know,
it's such a,
well it's interesting that books can,
you have,
have
sexuality like raw sexuality mixed in with the story,
but they can't have that in a movie.
Like a movie could never have people graphically fucking movie you just saw,
I just saw a movie people graphically fucking,
it was called blue is the warmest color.
It was a French French?
Yes.
Oh,
William.
Um,
remember Brown bunny.
Do you remember that?
Yeah.
That guys like black because that movie is he really?
What is his fucking name?
Vincent Gallo.
Yeah.
He mean,
I literally saw um,
these,
these people reviewing that movie or you know,
talk informally.
They were talking about it and they were like,
he's a piece of shit.
He'll never work again.
Wow.
And all because he made that Chloe's vendors girl,
she,
she just sucked his dick on screen and he came all over on screen.
Like you actually see him orgasm in the movie,
but the movie is before that,
a real movie.
It's like,
this is just a sex scene in a movie where you actually get to see the sex and
they decided to just go for it.
So they decided to make a movie and have,
why is it okay to have a sex scene where you don't see sex,
but when you have a sexy,
we see sex.
Like they were angry at him because he made them watch that.
Like that was,
I was listening to this man and he's two women talk about it and they're,
their specific point was that they were angry that he made them watch that he
made them more sense if they,
if they were watching the movie,
everybody had to know that that was [inaudible] everybody this,
I think they were one of the first people to see it.
And I think everybody that went in to see that movie knew there was a
controversial thing like that had gotten out.
But I don't think they realize you're gonna Watch Vincent Gallo literally put
his Dick in a girl's mouth.
And it was a long,
I mean I seen it wasn't like for a brief like American Werewolf in London.
Do you see the wolf and then it cuts to black.
Now this is like,
it wasn't just the size deck and you saw her mouth and then cut.
That might've been another blanket.
Do you think that,
I mean,
I didn't see the movie,
so I don't really have,
I didn't either,
but I watched the one second.
Do you think that that was like,
Hey,
do this or do you think it was really a form of artistic expression?
I personally think it was a form of artistic expression that he also wanted to
do.
I think it's both and I think that's part of what people got angry about with
the idea is that like I'm looking,
when I see a guy act really well,
I'm looking at Dick wagging already.
You know?
I mean that's what you're doing by excel,
but in your expression,
you know,
in your expression of,
the powerful,
the anger of your acting.
I'm looking at your tears,
you're screaming at someone.
I'm also aware that you're aware that you're awesome at doing that.
And then me being aware that you're aware that you're awesome and doing that,
there's a certain amount of inherent Dick Wagging.
It's one of the reasons why people have a,
like an almost automatic distaste for some famous men or some powerful man or
men that are in the public spotlight is cause they know they have to be at least
somewhat enamored of themselves,
which is a form of Dick Wagging.
So when you're doing that Dick Wagging and then you're also sticking your dick
in Chloe's of agendas,
diseases,
mouth,
like Jesus fucking Christ,
man,
you're double Dick Wagon.
That's what you're doing,
your Dick Wagon because you're up there on the big screen and your Dick Wagon
cause you're standing there and these ridiculous fucking tailored weird clothes.
Cause you want to be interesting.
If you're fucking handmade shoes,
I just want to hit you wanna fuck I saw the scene.
I don't really want to hit him.
I probably would get along with that.
Dude.
I probably like him.
You know,
I think he's probably a freak.
You should totally bring him on a podcast.
That's really interesting.
Well he wasn't around for a while and then he did a vodka commercial.
There was a vodka commercial that he was a part of,
some big uh,
vodka campaign.
But I don't know like what kind of films he's been in since then.
But I do know that there was from my limited amount of experience in show
business,
because I kind of,
when I started doing fear factor,
I basically divorced myself almost entirely of the acting world.
Sure.
You know,
it was only in it for like five years when I was doing news radio.
And then when I started doing that I just Kinda,
I was just out of that world.
So I never,
I never hung out with those people,
not around those people.
But when I did,
my limited interaction with people led me to,
to think that they're probably like almost universally people wanted him
blackballed because that movie,
Oh I think it was so common
boundary of like,
you know,
if you have like
when people have controversial sex scenes that come up,
like I kind of remember eyes wide shut.
That's just what comes to mind.
When that movie came out,
people were like,
oh my God,
you know,
there's some serious shit in there.
And then,
you know,
keep pushing the envelope.
But I think you know what actual sex scene in a non quote unquote pornographic
film.
It's like all of a sudden all the filmmakers are like,
oh,
what the fuck,
what,
you know,
why did you,
you totally like,
you know,
shooting almost.
You can do that.
And I know everybody's paying attention to it.
Yeah,
well it just,
it's not,
um,
the,
the formal kind of traditional sense of a sex scene.
So I'm sure filmmakers would be a little bit perturbed,
but I don't give a shit.
That's just my take on it.
Apparently homeboys still doing movies for him.
He did buffalo 66 was a really interesting movie to Brown bunny was in 2004 and
he did a couple of movies since then,
you know,
here and there like little parts and weird shit that,
do you ever get um,
movie offers or yeah,
like that these days.
Yeah.
Not good ones,
but yeah,
they're never,
it's never worth it because it might even,
it was like one of them was a big movie,
but it wasn't that much money and I had to go somewhere for like a couple of
weeks and I was like,
you gotta you gotta pay me a lot of money and it's gotta be worth my while.
It's going to be interesting for me to want to do it or I got to know somebody
in it that I'm gonna enjoy hanging out with.
Sure.
Like otherwise,
like I'd rather just do a free podcast.
Sounds ridiculous.
I'd rather do a set of the ice house,
like at a certain point in time it's like,
what do you want?
Do you want a bunch of money or do you want to do things that you enjoyed doing?
And the more you say,
I want a bunch of money,
the less you're going to do things you enjoy doing.
And the more you say,
I want to do things I enjoy doing somehow or another,
the more money you start making.
Yeah,
it doesn't make any sense.
And that's it.
Let's do that.
Doing it.
Yeah.
Money.
Actually,
you know what,
I'll be honest with you.
Um,
please do.
It's been,
you know,
I think I'm always honest.
Um,
but hey,
well please don't tell me that.
Um,
make it seem like a special moment.
We've had a really great year so far as far as um,
great year so far as far as shows that have been coming in.
Like we've had a few private gigs where those are,
are really,
um,
fruitful.
You know,
someone's like,
literally,
we actually,
um,
this was amazing to play to a Gig for a birthday party,
but it was a very,
um,
well set up.
It was the 21st birthday party.
This girl 2021 years old.
Um,
but her,
her father's a Microsoft exec and they are fans of our band and it was such a
great opportunity to make new friends,
but also,
you know,
get,
get paid well,
which was actually really cool because that's helping us finish this record and
things like that kind of keep happening.
We're getting these phone calls of like someone saying,
Hey,
we have this festival.
It's a small town festival,
but we'd love to bring you in and you know,
it's all kind of working out,
you know,
in a way that we're really grateful for because it's sort of like,
we've been doing this for eight years,
you know,
and it's nice to have those things when they come up and not have to have a side
job right now.
Yeah.
Well you guys are really fucking talented and the world is very strange right
now when it comes to music.
It's just the way to distribute things is gone topsy turvy the record companies
are whack that stuff.
It's,
it's,
you just have to figure,
you have to do it on your own and internet and will the Internet,
we,
we have,
uh,
you can do live shows.
There's a thing called stage it and we've done a few of those and we're actually
going to do one soon.
Um,
but,
but touring,
you know,
touring just can't sell records anymore.
It's not the same.
About the same.
No,
it's not like,
but we actually have,
like when we went to Europe,
we actually just got off the road,
uh,
this past,
at the end of last year,
we opened up for a guy named Jake Bugg
and
well we got,
you can't bite the hand that man,
we totally,
it was amazing.
Now he's a,
he's like a British rock sensation.
Oh cool.
When he took us overseas with them and it was amazing.
It was really hard.
Like we got our asses handed to us and in the UK that was,
um,
rowdy crowds and we played as a duo in front of like 6,000 people instead of
like when we played the full band and you get like drums and bass and it's like,
you know,
router rounds man.
But I'll tell you what,
England was rough on us,
but Europe was amazing.
They,
uh,
were probably some of the best crowds we've ever had.
You guys have opened for quite a few famous people.
Who else were you guys opened for?
We,
what'd we do last?
We did show crow wheel.
Yeah,
that's what I was talking about.
What was Alex?
It was great.
Man.
She,
she likes to hang out with.
She's super sweet.
She just kept everything she did.
She did have these little speeches during her set talking about how she needed
to,
we had a Kickstarter at the time.
I don't think she really understood the concept of to get you guys some money at
your Kickstarter.
Yeah.
But she'd say things like,
vote for honey,
honey.
That's not,
no,
it's not a
campaign as a difference.
So cool though.
That's so cool.
She was amazing.
She's got a beautiful voice,
ma'am.
She's a beautiful woman.
Like just,
she's really,
and she's like an empire builder too.
That's what it's so cool to see the people in her position.
We'll figure it out.
Okay.
I've had this,
I've had a successful music career,
but I can just branch out now.
This whole universe of show crow.
Right,
right,
right.
Yeah.
I enjoy her music,
man.
Aye.
What time?
I was in my car and my friend Eddie,
uh,
it was in the car with me and he asked me if I could,
give his girlfriend a ride somewhere.
So she hopped in the car and Sheryl Crow was playing and uh,
it was like,
is this a joke?
Like you're playing this as a joke?
And I'm like,
I like Sheryl Crow.
And was like,
no,
you don't.
Like Sheryl Crow became like an argument with her and I,
whether or not I like Sheryl Crow.
You being ironic like,
no,
my favorite mistake is like a great fucking song.
It's a beautiful song.
She's like,
no,
you're,
you're like a monkey.
Like you're like eight.
When she was like mocking me,
it was all in fun.
It was in good fun.
She's like,
shouldn't be be listening to like death metal or something or something with a
confederate flag attached to it
doing your show.
We have all these dudes come up.
I know we've told you that.
Yeah.
These dudes come out tatted up six foot five and we playing a ballad and just be
like,
you know,
screaming before the show,
during the ballads.
It's amazing.
We have the nicest,
they're the best and everyone always asks about your like
great hugs.
It's really
cool when we guys,
when we guys word and we did that show together.
December 21st,
2012 shell.
That was fun to shit.
That was the first and only time I've ever done a show like that or it was Doug.
Stan hope.
Joey Diaz.
You guys.
Yeah.
Fuck yeah,
I'm in.
Let's do it.
I'm totally down.
We could totally do that again if that was really fun.
It was really interesting to Nashville weird people out.
What's that?
Do it the international?
Yeah,
I kind of,
I have a friend who has a club in Nashville.
I'm in town.
I do his club.
Yeah,
he supports comedy.
It's like this is not a big scene.
The clubs,
there's a weird thing with me with certain certain small clubs like I kind of
have to do them.
I said I have to support them and that's one of them.
It's like not a lot of comedy out there.
I feel like he's an island in the,
you know,
and I know he gets good acts there on a regular basis,
but I always feel the need.
Like the Ice House is another one.
Like I would never do a theater in Pasadena.
It's never going to happen.
If I'm in Pasadena,
I do the ice house just because of the fee owners is my friend.
And it's supports comedy.
Loyalty.
It's fucking awesome.
Well,
it's that.
It's also,
you don't,
I don't need to do anything else.
You know what I mean?
It's not like a desperate moment where if I don't do the theater,
my kid's going to be hungry.
You know,
you
were on fire.
That end of the world show was amazing.
There was something magical happening that night.
It was fun.
And Doug,
Stan Hope,
oh,
he's awesome.
And Joey and Joey Diaz is awesome.
God,
that show couldn't have been more fun.
It was beautiful.
It was a beautiful show.
The audience was so nice too.
They were so fun and so they enjoyed it so much.
It was just so cool.
You know?
That's the one most surprising thing about all this is not just the connection
to all these people that we've sort of like somehow or another fostered,
but how nice they are.
Like when we do shows like we do shit.
I did show the other day in Chicago and after the show I took pictures of the
pizza for two hours cause went outside and I said anybody who wants to take a
picture,
I said I'll be here until the last one he leave.
I stood on a behind a table and I just,
I said this is what we're going to do.
I'll do five minutes on this side,
five minutes in the middle and then in five minutes on that side and then we'll
keep switching and we just went every five minutes and I set my timer on my
phone and at five minutes I bet.
All right I'm moving,
I'm moving.
Then I'd go do this side.
Like it was just a swarm of people around these tables.
But what my point was was for two hours nobody was a dick,
not one person.
Everyone was cool as fuck.
Not,
why would the person,
this is actually Dallas I did in Chicago too,
but this is the most recent was Dallas.
But it was just no one at all.
Like nothing.
Not One person.
No one tried to cut in line.
No one was a shithead knowing
Dick to you.
I'm like,
well to anybody we've seen a little bit of that.
You see people not even with us necessarily.
We tour with other acts and people at the merch booth get aggressive with
whoever's signing say,
hey,
this is what I want.
Give me basically you owe this to me.
That kind of mentality.
It does happen.
I think it all,
I mean,
I don't know cause I,
I'm trying to figure out how this happened,
you know,
cause isn't,
it never happened to me before,
like before the podcast and before,
um,
you know,
social media essentially when I was dealing with people,
I was dealing with people that knew me from something else.
They knew me from fear factor or they knew me from the UFC or the new me from
news radio,
you know,
or they knew me from comedy.
Those were the options.
It wasn't.
They knew me like these people just all know me.
It's weird.
It's totally different.
It's like they say hi like they know me,
you know like dude,
what's up?
And I'm like,
What's going on?
You know,
it's,
it's very strange.
I mean they get,
you get to reveal these really amazing parts of yourself and your,
and your mind on your podcast.
And I think that's such a great thing about what you're doing and what,
you know,
most podcasts,
if they're good ones,
you know,
you have,
you create good conversation,
you create real situations of,
of conversation and people get to witness that.
And that's so cool.
While they also get to be a part of it,
you know,
because they get to see the whole thing.
Like one of the things I like about this pod,
cause we don't,
we don't like edited,
it goes out live.
It's all,
you know,
it is what it is.
And because of that you kind of get to see who everybody really is.
If it was really produced and there was all these fast edits and there was all
this,
you know,
really preplan segments and it would feel less like you were really there.
You might enjoy it still,
but you wouldn't feel like you know the people that well.
Yeah.
And at people that are stuck in some shit spot wherever the fuck you are.
If you're in Bangor,
Maine or not,
not to be smirch Bangor,
it's a fine community.
But if you're anywhere,
if you're in some weird spot and you know you don't have a lot of cool people
around you,
you could listen to honey honey talk,
you can listen to Adam Carolla,
you could,
you know there's,
there's a bunch of people that you're going to get to listen to the way they
think.
And I know for a fact that I have part of who I am has been formed by listen to
be before smarter and more experienced in myself talk and that there,
there are thoughts shaped my reality.
And so to be able to introduce other people to the thoughts and ideas that have
shaped my reality,
my thoughts and ideas that I've gotten from those thoughts and ideas and other
people's thoughts and ideas that continue to shape my reality.
It's not just me putting on a show,
it's me being a part of it and the audience be a party of it too.
Everyone's a part of it.
It's like,
I'll tell you what,
I think that it's an incredible thing that you're doing that and you're
continuing to do that because if the majority of people are watching bullshit
reality shows,
you know,
where they're scripted and staged and they're supposed to do these candid,
um,
examples of,
of really asinine shit,
it really annoys me.
You know,
like real housewives and it's like,
right?
Like trying to make something like,
Oh,
you're,
you're wearing the same dress as me or whatever.
The fuck be important and I'm going to fight you.
I don't even know.
I don't watch that shit.
Right.
I think it's,
it's bad for you,
right?
I think that it lowers your
vibration.
You know what I mean?
Like,
and,
and when you're,
you're doing what you're doing,
which is um,
being,
I think you're brilliant,
I'm not trying to be weird,
but you're,
you have this incredible mind and you share it with people and lots of different
people and you have these situations,
it's really great to listen to and you're right.
People learn from it.
Well I'm definitely not brilliant but what I am is curious and have a lot of
free time and so I keep thinking about shit because I have the ability to do so.
I mean I don't know if people were like born to do anything in life.
I don't know if anybody was born to do anything in life but I think for sure if
you follow your passion,
you feel like you were born to do this if for sure if you actually do what you
enjoy out of life.
And there was some really weak ass article that somebody posted the other day
that I'm sick and tired of rich people saying to follow your passion.
It was hilariously stupid.
Whoever,
whatever dumb ass road.
And he actually had to change the title the next day because of a barrage of
hate that he,
he got from it when it was about Richard Branson and a bunch of people saying,
follow your passion.
And he was saying essentially that most people shouldn't follow their passion
and in fact they should keep their passion as a hobby.
Yeah.
You know why?
Cause he's a weak bitch.
He's a week
and he's worried that he possibly wasted his life writing shitty articles like
this.
And in fact he did.
And he was also talking about how fortunate he is personally to do what he does.
But all these self deprecating throws to poverty in it and all this nonsense in
it.
I sent you,
essentially what he's doing was who's a writing a thing that was downplaying
greatness and inspiration.
And when someone says follow your passion,
you know,
if anybody that says don't do that is a fucking idiot.
Because here's the thing,
if you love making guitars,
okay,
and you just love guitars,
you left making guitars.
He said,
God,
I would love to make guitars for living.
Someone fucking does that.
Okay.
There's a guy out there and he gets up every morning and he makes fucking
guitars and if that's what he loves to do,
that guy loves life.
We're not talking about breathing underwater.
Fuck face.
We're not talking about flying to the moon with a fucking rubber band.
We're talking about making guitars.
If your passion is making guitars and you read that asshole's article which
says,
don't follow your passion,
fuck you stupid.
Fuck you.
You weak dummy.
You fucking disease of ideas.
You're a disease idea.
That's what you are.
You're a rotten little weak man with poor hormones and you can't figure out that
your passion doesn't necessarily mean rich like I'm so tired of rich people
saying,
follow your passion.
Shut,
fuck up.
What difference does it make if they're rich,
everyone should say,
follow your passion.
That's how buildings got made.
That's why airplanes were invented.
That's why you could watch fucking television because someone followed their
passion.
What happens when you read Lord of the Rings?
You're reading someone's passion,
you're wearing clothes,
you're wearing passion,
you're listening to music,
you're listening to passion.
I'm reading your stupid fucking article.
Your lack of passion is your passion.
Your lack of following your passion is what you're so passionate about
portraying.
Shut up to him,
man.
Shut up.
Hey Man,
I'm going to hold you down.
And a buddy,
your scone,
you fuckhead,
who is the name?
What's the name of Diego?
Peru for toning.
Powerful Diego.
Peru for 20
fucking Tommy.
Follow your passion guide again,
honey.
Honey is following their passion or the mom and dad.
I get the feeling,
I mean that guy.
I don't really to point out like if that guy listens to this,
like Joe Rogan hates me,
smirked at me.
I don't really hate that guy at all.
I just would,
I would advise against further communications in that sort of thing.
Don't be a naysayer.
You know what I mean?
Let,
let somebody have their fucking moment.
Let somebody fail if they're going to fail or succeed.
I understand.
I truly understand his point.
But W,
W,
w you know,
I mean,
but his,
all of his,
you know,
his talk,
one of the things that Richard Branson said,
you should have a couch in your kitchen and this guy was like taking issue with,
if your kitchen is big enough to have a couch in it,
like stop,
stop.
It doesn't mean you're rich.
A lot of people give,
get
a kid fucking couch and a kitchen.
She shut the fuck up.
You know,
like I hate that real obvious pandering or I can't afford to have a coach in my
kitchen.
My kitchen is not big enough.
Like,
well fucking whatever dude.
You know,
you're talking nonsense.
There's God,
there's a better message than that.
It's not,
it's not,
you know,
don't follow your passions.
It's not,
you're better off keeping your passions as your hobby.
That is absolutely ridiculous.
And the only person that was any choice in life that's,
that doesn't make any sense.
The person that would say that as a person who hasn't followed their passions,
it doesn't make a living off of it because if you can make a living off of it.
I do not work.
I don't work.
I don't have any jobs.
Even my jobs are not jobs and I'm not the only one.
I know people that make pool cues.
My friend Eric,
he makes pool cues.
It makes beautiful pool cues.
He doesn't work.
I mean he makes pool cues.
He loves it.
He makes them for free and gives them out to people sometimes because he loves
doing it.
He loves would.
He loves creating things,
construct.
He started doing it while he was in the military.
He did it as a hobby just for fun cause he loves doing it,
you know,
and so when he's making money doing it,
he's not really working.
What he's doing is following his passion and if you could figure out a way to do
that for money,
God dammit.
Why would you ever try to encourage someone to not do that?
That's so crazy.
It's even what we were talking about before.
If you just start doing it,
eventually the money's going to reveal itself.
Hopefully the support,
maybe it's not,
you know,
your whole lifestyle is being provided for,
but you can do something with it.
Yeah.
Hopefully.
Unless you like make weird shit like custom badminton rackets and nobody wants
to buy toothpick tps or something going to something that's your passion.
Some days it's going to catch on.
So weird shit.
People do well shit,
it's amazing and sometimes weird.
Shit's worth a lot of money.
Like I saw something,
it was a Faberge egg that someone found in like a garage sale or something like
that and they,
it was worth like 10 million bucks.
No,
I do you see that?
No.
Pull that article up.
Faberge egg found.
They were like trying to collect scrap,
but I looked at it,
I was like,
oh my God,
I wouldn't give you a dollar for that.
If you had that in my house,
I'd fucking push it out the door.
You try to leave it in the house.
I was like,
no,
you can't leave this here.
You're so,
it's so funny.
Recently,
I,
I was,
uh,
I saw this article on beanie babies and it was like worth like $10,000 or,
and I was like,
Holy Shit.
Like my grandmother sent us all these beanie babies.
Oh Wow.
Look at that.
Faberge a meal worth up to 20 million found by scrap metal dealer.
What are you going to do with it?
How is that worth $20 million month that in my bathroom,
that is so dumb.
The idea that that's where 20 million bucks,
it's
silly,
but you know,
you got to let somebody have their passion.
If that Faberge egg egg.
That's what I said.
Yeah.
But he traps,
I mean,
I guess maybe it's like really beautiful upclose yes.
So recently I was a,
I saw this article on being babies and there's a collection in my parents'
basement given to us by my grandparents.
When we were kids,
my grandma would send like the Princess Diana
beanie baby and we have like,
there's like a hundred of them.
And so I was like,
I was like,
Ma Ma,
I'm going to go in the basement.
I think I'm gonna make some money.
I was like looking up all this shit,
hoping I could sell something on Ebay because they were going for like $15,000
for it.
But it had to be like,
it was really weird.
It had to be like,
um,
there would be like a technical flaw on the tag and somebody out there would pay
$15,000 for whatever.
It's so weird.
Yeah,
I didn't come up with anything good.
I was really bummed,
but I was downstairs in the basement for like an hour and a half trying to come
up with something
hustler.
Um,
the ones that we owe nothing,
maybe like 10 bucks,
10 bucks or 15 or less sentimental value of my grandmother Florence fantasy.
So man is amazing.
I see,
I understand it.
It's weird how things become like super worth money.
Very,
very expensive and it doesn't make sense.
And it was $500,000 and apparently he's this amazing hand built.
Why?
But it wasn't like covered in diamonds or anything like that.
It was just this amazing handcrafted watch.
But it's still just a watch just because it's hand crafted.
Like if someone gave you a handcrafted spoon would,
how much more would that be worth?
It was the handcrafted spoon made by Jimi Hendrix.
Fuck yeah,
I'd be pumped about that spoon.
I pay a few grand for a handcrafted spoon made by Jimi Hendrix.
Never eat soup without that spoon
spoon around my neck because I don't know.
It's like guitars.
You'll find guitars for 200 grand,
250 but most of the people that buy them don't play him too.
We'll just wants glass box.
Legendary.
They're irreplaceable.
There's know.
What is it like a 55 gold top?
The 59 Les Paul Gold.
Top news is worth a ridiculous amount of money.
I don't know.
It depends.
It always flexes.
But you could probably sell one for like a hundred grand.
There's,
it's like that with old cars now.
You know there's certain like old barracudas that are worth over a million
dollars and this is the Plymouth,
a shitty old Plymouth and the ones they want are the ones that are completely
stock.
Like no new wheels,
no new tires,
no new interior,
everything stock,
everything from the factory,
little push button radio and people will pay exorbitant amounts to passion to
find one person
59 the less cross.
You just need one person to give enough of a shit to say that that's worth
$100,000 and then it is.
That's true.
It's like as soon as it becomes a demand,
right?
Yeah.
This weird thing,
especially if there's a finite amount,
like there's a finite amount of 1972
Volkswagens.
Yeah.
If you find a 1972 Volkswagen bug,
this is only a few of those that were ever made.
You know how many of them are are their lefts,
you know if you could get a pristine one becomes very valuable
about that is that some people actually make a business out of just the,
the tastemaking trend setting in general.
Like they might not even be like a car maven,
but they like,
they can be privy to the oncoming trend of,
do you know what I mean?
Like,
like all of a sudden everybody wants those 79 or whatever.
He said.
Volkswagens.
Yeah,
and then you could just be like this trader,
you know the Ebay middleman traitor.
No,
I mean trader traders.
Yeah.
Those are the sweet old Volkswagen.
My Buddy Jimmy Lawless used to have one of those when we were 18 prowl around
and this fucking little tiny Volkswagen is at 18 yeah.
His name is Jimmy.
Lost his whole life.
Pretty hardcore.
No,
Jimmy was a good dude.
Yeah.
Jimmy's a bad ass name.
Yeah,
it is.
I was always jealous.
We've recently come across some great names.
I met somebody in England and his last name was dragon.
Oh Shit.
Wake up every morning just feeling like you're fucking rocket rockets.
Yeah.
There was a rocket,
one of my best friends named Eddie Bravo.
That's ridiculous.
Yeah.
That guy,
the bravos ridiculous name.
People do believe it's a real name.
Come on letter.
Your name.
That's his fucking name.
Yeah,
that's a,
I was stuck with Joe Joe Rogan.
It's very boring stuff in their name.
That's all right now I made something out of it.
It's easy to spell.
Yeah.
Egg is the baddest motherfucker vol time because they came up to him and they
told him,
you got to change that shit.
And he's like,
well,
I don't think so.
Got Dude's name.
What is the original Santa Su?
So damn,
that's even better.
Oh Man.
When you go solo,
well,
you know,
why are you trying to
be supportive in man
fucking bullshitting?
I just can't help it.
I can't help it.
I have bad instincts.
Oh Man.
Comedian instincts and always say something fucked up.
Destroy all day.
I find them all fucking day.
You know what,
we're,
we uh,
we've weathered the storms over the years.
It's been rough.
I'm sure.
Fucking rough.
Yeah.
Well you guys get along remarkably well.
And you know,
one of the things I really enjoy about hanging out with you guys is how,
look no one gets along 100% of the time.
It just doesn't work.
There's no human beings,
whether it's mother and son,
whether it's father and daughter,
whether it's brothers and sisters,
whether it's friends and neighbors.
No one gets along 100% of the time.
It's going to be bumps,
but you guys are,
you have a great energy about you,
like you guys are friends,
you guys are co creators,
your,
your collaborators.
You know,
you have a very unique bond because of that.
And it's interesting to pal around with you guys,
like to go to dinner with you,
hang out with you.
Cause your bond is,
is,
it's unique,
but it's also very pure.
And that sounds gross to say that hate,
hate my own words.
Fight pretty early on,
honestly.
You figured out how to fight each other and not have it not hurt each other.
Destroy.
Yeah.
But,
um,
well you don't insult each other.
That's,
you know,
I had,
I had a friend,
we were having this conversation a while back.
He was talking about his wife and he's like,
you know where everything's fine,
but man,
when we fight,
uh,
we both go for the drug dealer right away.
And I go like,
what do you,
yeah.
And I go,
what do you like?
What do you mean,
go for the jugular?
And he goes,
well,
you know,
we just,
we know the one thing that really fucks with each other.
So we automatically go to that and I go,
okay,
who's the first person is doing that?
You know,
I don't want to say,
you know what,
I think I'm in any situation where you're,
um,
you're introduced to conflict.
[inaudible] depending on like,
sometimes you want to fight,
you know,
it's like you can,
you can,
uh,
be quick with your words,
you know,
whatever it say mean shit,
but that,
that's kind of pointless.
You know,
at the end of the day,
usually you're fighting depending on who you're fighting with.
But like,
it's your loved ones,
at least in my disposition.
And I love them.
I don't want to hurt them.
So you,
when you approach,
you know,
a confrontation,
in my opinion,
this is something actually I really learned a lot.
My relationship with Ben in his band has made my other relationships in my life
so much better because we had,
because we have to fight it
so hard for,
um,
sometimes not all the time for this,
this union for our project.
And what we care about so much.
And so you have to be a good listener and you have to be humble and you have to
like,
you know,
put your fucking foot in your mouth sometimes.
And,
and when I approach a confrontation with like my sister or my mom and like my
family and I,
we love each other,
we love each other so much,
we fight hard,
you know,
and it sucks and it's painful.
Where are you guys like your fight?
Like get angry at each other?
Yeah,
there's a lot of stuff.
I'm not going to get into it but,
but stuff happens over a couple more drinks.
Keep easy Rogan.
I'm fucking watch yourself.
Um,
but the,
the point is that if you approach
any conflict or confrontation literally,
and I'm not trying to be weird with love and you're like,
I love this person and you listen you,
I think more often than not you can really come to a resolve or just a better
understanding of that person.
You will continue to learn more about people in your life.
It's not like you,
this,
you have this all encompassing knowledge of somebody you know
as useful side of fighting too.
Cause then we're hammering shit out that makes us not get along.
Maybe we would get along more in the future and figure out what it's been.
Maybe there's been something you've been doing,
which sucks.
And I need to get away from those people.
Yeah.
I had a girlfriend
once that really liked to fight and uh,
well,
you know,
it's all right.
I got rid of her.
She was a crazy bitch.
Like fuck.
But there was,
um,
there was one moment where we're,
we're heading out to some party and I guess she was stressed out or something
like that.
So she yelled at me like out of nowhere.
And uh,
and I just,
this is the first time she ever yelled at me and I go,
hey,
listen,
I grow,
we can't talk like this.
You can't,
you can't have this conversation with me like this.
Like,
are you not allowed to yell at me?
I go,
none of my friends yell at me.
No one yells at me.
I don't yell at him either.
I go,
if you're my friend,
why would you,
why do it?
Why would you yell at me?
You don't yell at me if you're more concerned with it.
Just exploding,
throwing up your own energy,
then you are with the repercussions is going to have on the people around you.
That's an ultimately very selfish thing to do.
And I go,
we can't,
we can't ever talk like that.
And she looks like immediate,
like deflated,
like all of her anger like went away.
It was a very weird moment and we just sat down and we had a conversation.
That tone exactly that.
The tone is everything.
That's pretty powerful man.
Tony do that well,
it was pretty powerful but she couldn't help herself.
She was,
she was,
I don't know what it was.
It was something that our child had because we wound up staying friends,
but we broke up and then she started dating some new guy and um,
she calls me up and she's like really frustrated.
She's really frustrated because she can't keep yelling at this.
She can't keep from yelling at this guy.
She keeps yelling at them and she doesn't know what to do.
She's like,
I yell at him and he takes it and I fucking keep yelling at them and I don't
know what to do.
I just can't.
I can't,
he,
he lets me bullying.
So I start fucking bullying him and she goes and I don't,
I can't even stop myself,
you know,
if you grow up with that.
Yeah.
Yelling and it's really funny like this is,
my mom is awesome but like I grew up with a lot of yelling.
My mom yelled a lot and I was bad.
So,
but this is kind of hysterical.
We had a family bird.
Um,
it was a boy,
but his name was Abby and he was an African grey and they're really smart.
They're really fucking smart animals and they repeat a lot of things and
literally the Bar,
my sisters,
I grew up with Carla and Jody,
like the bird would go Carla,
Jodi and then we'll go see to have is like total like this like fleur of like
screaming words that you couldn't understand.
But it was pretty accurate cause my,
I got yelled at a lot and my mom would yell at me and so it was always this
reminder,
like when I would walk in the room that sometimes the Burj next day,
God,
my mom never called me and kind.
That'd be horrible.
Really bad thing.
Well we fucking noise she made,
it's the same thing as calling your car.
But it's funny,
like we love each other so much,
but we fought a lot.
Oh Lord.
Oh,
that's rough.
But yeah,
yelling,
yelling is a,
is a difficult thing too as an adult now.
It's like,
um,
it's really funny,
but Ben,
you know,
we the other way my mom did,
she would just freeze me out.
Yeah.
To like
deep silence.
Oh,
that's worse.
Yeah.
Sometimes it's better if someone has enough caring for you that the yell at you
and fight with you.
Like you work it out.
Everybody gets tired of it and working it out.
Yeah.
You know,
but this girl,
um,
you know,
she wasn't a bad person and growing up later and becoming a dad,
I kind of really feel for her because I think that what happened with this,
this girl was just,
she was just programmed in a really shitty way by dummies and she grew up in
Florida and there are a bunch of dummies around her and she said,
yes,
Capitol of the United States,
zero killer caverns,
not cereal.
A lot of cocoa puffs crunched by fucking delicious.
You know,
I think that's a lot of it
who we are.
It's like how we were programmed when we were young and this girl was,
she wasn't a bad person.
She was just battling with a programming as she was trying to be an actress.
Which fucking good luck with all that.
It's really funny.
Sorry Ben,
go ahead.
I was just going to say,
isn't that what the neuroplasticity concept has those you can change that stuff.
You can,
but
you know,
neuroplasticity is all nice and good,
but if you were,
if you're that fucked up,
I recommend MTMA neural plasticity is really going to fucking get you to the
dance.
But what does that do?
Just kind of blast it all makes you feel,
it makes you understand love in a weird,
pure form.
You know?
I mean,
and people could say it's a drug,
but that drug by the way exists in everyone's brain right now as we speak.
What you,
what you're dealing with with dopamine and you know,
and Mtma is elevated dopamine levels,
elevated feelings of love and passion and connection to each other.
It's just,
you know,
somebody sent me this video,
it's really kind of interesting.
You'd probably find it Brian.
It's a Joe Rogan talks indirectly about rave culture.
And it was me talking about [inaudible] about setting up some sort of
psychedelic community and that it would be incredibly beneficial to people to
set up communities where we could figure out how to meet and everybody takes
something that would tune this all into this sort of frequency of,
of love.
And so someone took me talking about that and connected it to raves where if you
look up at that screen,
like anytime you've seen a rave like this,
99.9% of those people are on ecstasy.
You're looking at 15,000 people that are in this huge football arena and
they're,
they're dancing around and touching each other and having a great fucking time.
Why are they having such a great time?
How come they can get together and smush up like that?
And no one's a Dick?
I'll tell you why.
Because they're on ecstasy.
And when I say 99.9,
nine,
nine point whatever,
those people are,
assholes
shouldn't be a day.
Not necessarily.
Can I be honest with you?
I think that also,
um,
I read this book on collective joy.
Um,
it's really interesting because like back to our primitive tribal selves,
like,
you know,
when there would be like rain dances and the tribes would dance and they would
all move together,
you know,
there would be this collective sort of that people
would have coalescing between them.
And I,
like,
I recently have reconnected with dancing.
Like I went to,
I went to a party and there was a Dj and you know,
I have like a couple drinks,
whatever,
but like I wasn't on drugs at the time.
And um,
you know,
rarely,
but let's get into that later.
But,
um,
the,
the dancing that the movement with,
with the sound is a powerful thing.
Drugs or no drugs.
And I think there's something really interesting about it as far as a
collective,
you know,
group of people.
Well that's in harmony,
you know,
as a comedian,
that's what I essentially do for a living.
As a comedian,
what you're doing is connecting all these minds together in some sort of a
harmonious,
harmonious tribal function.
That's why the smaller the tribe usually,
generally the better it works,
you know.
But one of the weird things about this connection with the Internet is that
people are getting used to larger and larger numbers.
We've had shows was 3000 plus people and it feels like it's intimate.
You know,
it feels intimate.
Like everyone's tuned in 3000 people and they're all tuned in.
And May,
I mean directly tuned in responsible.
Like they feel like they're a part of what's going on.
But when,
when you really feel it more is when you could see everybody,
it's like 300 people.
So I think the number,
like when you get above 300 people,
things get squirrely.
Like you can handle it if the people the right people,
but most,
most of the time you better off with 300 people.
But what you're essentially doing is you're conducting like a tribal sort of a
bonding moment.
Like everybody's experiencing the same vibe.
Everybody.
So
well,
you know what Saint Paul,
yeah,
we were playing,
we had a show last week in St Paul and every once in a while we just get to play
to a group of about 300 people who is,
you know,
being seated with our music helps because when,
when we're a duo,
it's not really rhythmically heavy.
So you have a seat of group of people and they're just so willing and kind of
vulnerable to us taking charge and there's this energy that goes way beyond what
we can do.
And all of a sudden,
you know,
it's a,
it's a show between us and them and they're,
they're putting in more than we are,
you know?
And,
and those experiences,
they,
I don't know,
they haven't happened as,
as,
as often as we'd like,
but they seem to be happening more.
And it's an amazing feeling.
It's like it,
it's kind of a weightlessness when you're performing,
you don't have to think about it anymore.
Well,
we all need the audience.
You know,
the audience is for you and for comedians.
I think you,
we need it in a,
in a different way,
but it's similarly important.
You know,
what an audience is there to like,
let you know that they're tuning in to all this work that you've done.
They get all the things that you've said.
They,
they understand all the stuff that you've labored on and,
and,
and formed into these rhythmic sort of,
uh,
these pieces,
you know,
which is the song really is.
Yeah.
And W for Comedians,
it's not just like we,
it's fucking a hundred percent mandatory.
You can't even write it without them.
Like the writing changes when you're around them.
When they become a part of it and their laughter,
each crowd you perform in front of help shape the material,
it changes in material from week to week,
you know,
without,
without those other people,
without the other,
the involvement of the other people.
It really doesn't even exist.
It's weird.
I never think about this show,
but I was just thinking about American idol when we're talking about this.
The culture mattered every day.
You fucking liar.
You were saying about this show.
It's to never,
I'm,
I'm over the hill man.
No,
but I think that it's like a competition culture and I think that fucks it up.
Yeah.
It fucks it up a lot.
It helps the people that make it,
but it doesn't because then the fucking money just lines up.
What's that dude's names?
Pockets.
What's his name?
Simon.
Simon is in the fucking,
but he's in a giant mansion top of the hill
about this before on the podcast.
But it's,
it's important to bring up again.
And I think,
um,
uh,
things like the American idol,
a microwave mentality is really toxic to people to,
to have like this.
Um,
you know,
in Instagram,
all of this stuff happening,
you know,
you won this thing.
It's like you won the lottery.
The lottery is,
you know,
more often than not a really terrible thing.
And,
you know,
it's,
um,
it's tough,
you know,
being,
being a musician and then seeing that we know we've had several,
it's really funny,
we've had several invitations to be on these like competitive shows like,
and people were like,
we really want you to be a part of it.
And it always just feels so wrong.
To me.
It always feels like,
um,
you know,
you,
you lose,
you lose a lot to begin with.
Like the people that are involved when it take all of your,
you know,
publishing and stuff like that,
own you in a way.
And that,
and that does kind of come back to what you were talking about before is like,
we want you to sound like this and do this.
And saying this and fuck that,
you know,
but,
but at the same time,
not to talk about us,
but just the mentality of,
of the princess.
Like the fairy tale is,
is rough on people.
You know,
I don't,
I don't like it.
Sorry.
I agree with you 1000%,
but that's not a real number.
I really do.
I think that a,
I entered a contest once,
uh,
in Boston,
the WBCN comedy riot.
Those are the only contest to ever entered.
I lost in the finals.
I was like,
dammit,
no nice guy.
One can't be grudged to the gentleman who won,
who was a very nice guy.
Um,
but it was just like,
it's the idea of,
it was so silly.
It's like,
how can he,
I mean,
I guess you can judge based on what's best for you.
Like what do you,
what do you find the best?
But you can't have a music contest where you have a rap band and a country band
and a rock band and a folk band.
You can't because there's no best,
there's the best for you.
All right.
If it's me,
it's very likely a rap band is never going to win.
There's a,
there's a few rappers unless it's like nod or something like that.
There's a few rappers who really,
who really connect with me,
you know,
where I really feel like I appreciate what they're doing as an art form.
Too much of it is just braggadocious nonsense.
You know hip hop stuff too.
Cause it's just hard to hear what it's saying.
You
look at our new record is going to sound like,
I like it.
Go with it.
But it could be like some DMT word songs.
Well you know a fucking perfect.
Yeah,
exactly.
Love that.
I love their crazy bitch.
Oh,
I think you're free keys.
Interviews with her because apparently she just rims out everyone in interviews
here.
Yeah.
That bitch is crazy.
I'll have her on the podcast,
you know,
tough exterior.
I'll tie that bitch up.
David chose friends with her.
Perfect.
Let's do it and just make it happen.
Those guys trying to shirt for me.
I got a shirt,
a t shirt from them.
They're bad ass.
I love that word.
Coachella.
Before we played.
Yeah,
they're,
they're gangster.
They're pretty bad ass.
But I mean,
unless it's something like really unique like that,
it's hard for me to get into too much rap because it's just not my tune,
you know,
whatever.
It is not my frequency.
I'm a like a big fan of the black keys.
I'm a big fan of a band.
I don't know if you guys heard of them to call honey honey and uh,
they're probably one of my favorites then.
No,
it's not lame.
But if a lot of your friends are around and they're like football players or
something like that,
like don't play it in front of all the wind up.
Fuck you.
Oh,
where are you guys at?
Uh,
in April.
I would like to offer you something right now.
And he cannot,
he cannot say no.
I would like to tweet all of your dates.
Let me know anytime you're on where I'd be more than happy.
I do with everybody I do with everybody and no one gets annoyed.
Everybody is happy about it because they find out you here
don't get annoyed.
I
barely drink.
I appreciate that.
You guys get feel weird,
but it's no work at all for me and uh,
I would probably feel weird if I was asking you so,
uh,
so don't feel weird.
How about we make a deal?
You fucking tweet from me too.
All right.
Done.
You.
Let's make it happen.
Okay.
We made an agreement.
So all of your dates,
anytime you're anywhere,
every time you are anywhere.
Unless I'm hunting in Alaska,
which I will be doing soon,
I'm going to the Brooks range to fuck up a moose day.
Oh my God,
I can't.
That is to butcher it.
What happens now?
The whole moment.
What are you doing man?
I'm doing these days is fucking everyday I do podcasts.
Then I get home from podcasts.
I shoot bows and arrows.
I shot 150 hours yesterday with a 90 pound bow.
I'm not fucking around.
Fuck yeah,
bitch.
Listen to both.
You guys can come.
You got to sing songs.
Don't scare away the bears.
They hate our shit.
Well,
Steven Rinella,
who's the host of this show that I do called the meat eater.
I've done it show twice and I'm committing to doing it like four times a year.
We'd go out and hunt.
It's amazing shop.
The guy's a brilliant author and he's incredibly well read and go read it.
Just a brilliant guy who also happens to be a really bad ass hunter who's really
into what they call fair chase hunting.
And the fair chase hunting is he won't hunt.
And if caged environment,
he's not going to hunt even if it's 10,000 acres.
If there's a fence up,
he's not hunting there,
you know,
he,
he will hunt wild land,
you know,
pup mostly public land some,
but it has to be a wild animal,
you know.
And um,
one of the things that uh,
we're trying to figure out,
it's something we could do together.
My thought of what we can do together is take people who've never hunted before,
hunting like honey,
honey,
dude,
we down.
Would you like to hunt something ugly and like a that people aren't really into
like pigs first?
Like it's a good one.
I heard that there's some crazy,
we have friends who live up in and I got a place and these dudes,
it's like a culture of dudes up there who go out knife hunting boards.
I'm not going to force you guys to do that.
I'm not interested in that either.
I'm not interested in it.
But there's a place called to hone ranch and we have a relationship with them
and they're only an hour and a half north of here is the biggest ranch in
California,
270,000 acres and they have 50,000 pigs.
It's insane.
They're infested with pigs.
What is our weapon of choice?
Are we bow and Arrow or no?
No,
no,
no.
It takes a long time to get good with a bow and Arrow,
like hundreds and hundreds of it.
I have a bone there all on scheduled for June.
One of the reasons,
Jude,
if you killed a few fucking wild pig for the shooting star,
you'd be my new hero.
I wouldn't suck a Dick,
but I'd let you lay it on my forehead.
Okay.
Tell your picture.
I'd probably get me there to be honest.
You must train,
but it's really hard to fucking,
it's really hard to shoot a pig with a bow and arrow with a throwing knife.
It's virtually impossible with a star.
Goddammit,
you're talking to fantasy,
but with a rifle we can get the job done with a rifle.
It's not hard at all.
We've shot some rifles.
You need a really good hunting rifle and a good guide.
But this place to hone ranch is,
like I said,
an hour and a half north of La and it's enormous and it's all wild.
There's no fences.
It's just a huge piece of property that these animals congregate on.
No,
during the day it's illegal to hunt at night and hard to see.
Awesome.
Well you can use in Texas in Texas.
They do.
That's crazy.
I've never actually hunted.
I've been thinking about it though,
honestly because I started eating meat again and I just realized like if I'm
willing to take this shit shrink wrapped from a freezer and a store,
I need to be okay with killing it.
Well,
why we speak my,
I have a ham that's brining that I shot a couple of months ago.
I shot a pig
to hone ranch.
I shot that deer to that,
that head right in front of you.
This,
this beautiful.
It was,
it put that on my wall.
It was slightly more beautiful when was wandering around.
But way more delicious efforts.
Boned out.
What does your bleach,
no,
I brought it to a guy who does that professionally and uh,
they take the brains out and bleach it down.
You don't want to keep some stinky brains.
You know how they do it?
They use a type of a bug that they use to clean off,
um,
cadaver bones.
It's called a super warm,
I know about this because we actually a fed it to people on fear factor,
know that it's fucked up.
It's pretty dope.
It takes a while to,
they leave the,
uh,
the skull with the super worms for quite a while and they just go to work and
they chew off every single ounce of flesh.
He take the,
the skull,
you put it into,
I don't know what you do.
It takes a few weeks.
The worms eat.
No,
but I mean,
so then they have this new move onto the next call.
Then the next guy got a fucking,
just goes from cadaver to cadaver.
Well,
there's this thing that they do,
um,
where you can get a head mounted after you shoot a deer,
like a trophy.
You can get it mounted and they take it and they put like glass eyes in it and
they leave the skin on and they do a taxidermy thing,
which is a little odd.
You know,
he shot this guy,
this guy.
Which one?
The page.
Oh,
the Predator.
That's a friend of mine's a buddy.
I got him tickets for the UFC.
I wish I could remember his name off the top of my head.
I want to say Steve.
He's a,
a special effects guy.
And the,
uh,
the guy,
Pat Mcgee did the American Werewolf who's a,
that's out in the
front area.
You're going to be going up against those in Alaska.
No.
You know what?
Uh,
this,
uh,
show mediator.
They know exactly what they're doing.
They know where to go.
You're always going to deal with bears,
but you just have to make sure that you scare him off and you keep an eye on
him.
And there's a lot of guys with guns and you don't want to hurt the bears,
but you know what the bear is stealing your Caribou.
You gotta be real careful.
Well,
it's not even fucking what does that 20 worst pieces of terrible taxidermy.
There's like cross site
that Puma came near me.
Hello?
Hey.
Hey Man.
You know where the bus stop is?
Yeah,
that is weird.
That is weird.
I'll mix them together.
Suzanne,
when you get back,
we're going to sing some songs.
No,
that's a guy who,
who shot the front legs out of the fucking missile.
Weird.
You know,
I mean,
it's a weird thing.
I would never shoot an animal just to make a trophy out of it and never in a
million years.
But if I found an animal in my backyard and it was dangerous and I shot it and
they said,
do you want to make a trophy out of it and be like,
fuck yeah,
all about context.
That's a tone.
That wolf is ridiculous.
Do you know that there's a concern right now that wolves might eventually start
to,
uh,
reemerge in Paris?
I have not heard that.
They're starting to make their way closer and closer towards Paris and they're,
and they're really worried right now that there might be a moment in the
somewhat near future when wolves once again are in Paris.
Well,
that's the crazy thing,
man.
They kill people.
Wolves killed like 40 people in Paris in the 14 hundreds.
There's a,
yeah,
it's like a famous incident where I'll pull it up right now,
the wolves of Paris.
There's a few books about it.
Awesome.
Yeah,
it's fucking scary as shit.
The American,
I mean,
is that where American Werewolf from Paris comes from?
No,
that's because the American Werewolf in London needed to seek cover.
Hi God.
That's a beautiful little cutie pie.
And I love wolves.
People are like,
Oh,
you're fucking,
you want to kill all the wolves?
I don't.
I love wolves.
Don't get me wrong.
I love wolves out there being all Wolfie.
My problem is when wolves come anywhere near people I care about,
I want them dead.
I want that family.
Dad was the shirtless dude.
Wolves in pairs.
The other guys got a little tiny little coyote dick,
he's trying to pass off as a lone
wolves of Paris.
Is that as band or his book?
I think it's a,
it's a book.
It's a sequel to 50 shades of purple that comes out after 50 shades of grey.
They run out of shit to talk about with color.
So they go with animals.
Woves a Paris.
When I was in Paris,
I had a,
he had a wolf ambulate on he ball gag me.
Yeah,
so we,
you missed a lot in Paris in 1450 40 human beings were killed by wolves.
Yeah.
Well we were talking about on wolves.
No regular walls.
There's a,
an issue.
Right now we're wolves are getting closer and closer to Paris and they're
worried about wolves reemerging in Paris because they have very strict
environmental.
Yes,
they have.
Yeah.
They have very strict environmental rules.
As far as a animals you're allowed to kill and not kill.
And the wolves,
wolves,
like the regular car,
timber wolves are,
well,
there's really only one kind of wolf.
Um,
like I got explain that by,
uh,
this Guy Steve Rinella.
I do this hunting show with like pigs.
There's only one kind of pig.
Like when you talk about wild pigs,
there is literally only one type of pig.
Wild or domestic is the same thing.
It's called [inaudible].
That's the type of animal.
Okay.
I didn't know that.
But Wolves,
same thing.
There's just wolves,
gray wolf,
timber,
Wolf.
It's essentially like the difference between,
you know,
human beings as human beings that live in Jamaica,
that human beings that live in Tennessee,
but they're just human beings.
That's it.
Exactly.
They have bigger decks.
But wolves.
Uh,
that was one of the issues with wolves that are brought in from Canada because
they brought in wolves to Canada and they repopulated a Yellowstone.
Really?
Yeah.
And a lot of other places.
Do we play that Jamie?
We did play that.
Wolves change rivers.
Do we play that?
Yeah,
we did.
There's a great documentary for those who have not seen it.
It's called a wolves changed the course of rivers in Yellowstone and it's,
it's amazing.
And uh,
it's fascinating how just the reintroduction of wolves to Yellowstone national
park has actually changed the way the rivers flow.
It's fucking incredible shit.
I'm not anti,
well,
I'm not anti anything.
I am not anti.
I talked shit.
Okay.
I don't mean what I say and people need to understand that there's a lot of the
shit I'm not,
I,
I hope they die in a fire.
My spirit animal,
conti,
Conti,
little shitty dogs that want to eat babies.
You say that unless you were alone with a wolf,
you're like Chuck Norris and Lone Wolf.
Mcquade
an affinity for like birds of prey and wolves and things like that.
Have you ever met an eagle in the wild?
No,
but I fucking like,
I would freak out.
I love you so much.
What's so funny?
Have you ever met an eagle and go,
wow,
I can't wait.
[inaudible] you're going to dance with the devil in the Pale moonlight.
An Eagle in the wild is very different than an eagle that's in a zoo.
That's what I'm saying.
I've never seen a negro
growing up in Minnesota.
Eagles and Minnesota.
Are you kidding me?
They call themselves
gang members in fucking Irvine.
I was in Alaska with Ari Shaffir.
We went,
we went salmon fishing.
Oh,
a bunch
of eagles.
It was fucking freaky.
Yeah.
Did you call any to your arm?
Your outstretched arm?
Oh,
there's none of that going on,
dude.
They'll eat your face.
They don't.
One thing that looking at you is like,
can I carry this guy away?
Too Big?
If you were a baby,
her fucking eat your asshole
eagles are essentially dinosaurs that made it.
That's all they are.
What do you think about the act of this riff that purchased by Facebook?
That great,
amazing.
I'm very fucking excited about that actually.
I'm just excited if there's more financial resources behind the process of
Oculus rift or the,
uh,
the,
rather,
not the proxy Sassy,
um,
technology.
Yeah.
I just hope I that if Facebook seems cool,
it's like,
you know,
one of the things that we were talking about recently was about that I find very
encouraging about this new tech money is that these guys,
whether it's the Google people or the Facebook people,
they seem ethical.
You know,
they seem they're making a shitload of money,
but their,
their intentions seem fairly pure.
Yeah.
And it's gotten more serious just from this purchase,
where before it was still kind of like an,
you know,
not many people knew about it kind of mind.
Now it's,
you know,
everyone's going to know about this and a couple of years.
So I think it's good.
I couldn't agree more.
I love that fucking Zuckerberg fucking Weirdo.
Yeah.
I think he's beautiful.
Kim.
Him a kiss right in the mouth is in the room.
You have a Facebook page?
Yeah,
I do.
I have a,
I'm a fan page.
I can't respond to emails,
so please don't,
I can't get,
I just can't get into the hat to you.
I'm not saying that to you saying to the other vps.
Don't Ben Tardy.
You fucking email me dude.
Chill.
What are you doing?
No.
Shut up.
You're hunting.
No Way.
It's impossible.
Let me show you my knife.
Uh,
is that a euphemism
that was showing you my blades show you,
man.
You Metaphor.
Why?
It's shaped like an elephant's trunk.
It's Dell,
but it's look,
cut your soul.
Effective.
Vaguely effective.
What are you guys gonna play?
Oh,
sorry.
We can play a song called big man.
My good friends.
The only band I've ever worked with ever.
In real life.
Yeah.
What are you gonna play?
Big Man.
That's a song we're going to play real life.
Well,
the only with us,
Joe,
when you put some jobs,
I feel like you could get some drums.
I want to just watch.
Do too many things.
Play drums.
Supergroup
been skin flicks.
The penis obvious here.
This.
Okay guys hit it.
Let it go.
Hey,
how's that work?
Oh Hey.
When the pig man,
they spill Bucky.
Yay
Bell.
No
Man,
baby,
Eh,
low tech,
eh.
Oh Man.
Ooh.
And they came.
Wow.
Hey Jane,
calm.
Hey
damn man.
You can try head off.
They be
part of some Greek plan.
Maybe no one should ever,
ever down in La.
Oh
bones.
Berry
Barry Ede.
Okay,
Shay
too,
please.
And he
was
it.
Damn man.
Damn the check.
Oh,
awesome.
That's a beautiful song.
Shit.
Nice mine.
Is that one of the ones going to be in the new special?
That's the idea.
That's what you're shooting for.
You guys have a name
for the record?
No,
no,
not yet.
But we're open to ideas,
but you know,
can I be honest?
We're really,
um,
we're working with a new dude this weekend.
That's why we're here.
And a new producer.
Yeah.
I'm really,
really honored and excited that he really wants to work with us and it's kind of
sort of like a trial run,
so fingers crossed.
He's our guy.
Awesome.
Yeah,
but it's,
it's,
it's fucking hard.
Listen,
I know.
It is.
Um,
you know,
it's,
it's easy for me to say,
I know it's hard,
you know,
but I've watched you guys,
I know,
I at least know from observing your struggle and I have friends that are
musicians,
could have friends,
you know,
like Everlast who's made it and,
and friends who are still struggling.
And I know it's a crazy business.
It ain't easy,
you know,
but you guys are talented as fuck.
Now,
buy your shit all day.
You know,
I'm honored to be friends with you guys,
but if I wasn't friends with the guys,
I would buy the fucking shit out of your music.
I love it.
I became a fan when I saw that,
uh,
Angel of Death Acoustic version that you guys did on a roof somewhere here in
la.
Yeah,
back in the days.
Yeah.
It's so cool that you can find someone like that.
I can see you guys.
Yeah.
And then all of a sudden we're hanging.
We're friends.
It's awesome.
We live in awesome times,
man.
It's just beautiful.
It's beautiful there.
And there was no middleman.
We all made that happen together,
you know,
just great.
It's fucking incredible.
That's what's been happening more and more too,
is being able to just talk to the people who are supporting us.
Why?
Oh honey,
honey podcast.
Why don't you guys start doing a podcast?
Fuck yeah.
That's a year
talking to the mic.
Yeah.
Especially when you guys are on the road.
You could just,
yeah,
to Mike's and you know,
doing a hotel room or like Suzanne,
I saw that little thing you did.
We interview in the cap.
I saw.
Yeah,
I saw you in the cat.
That was before we ever met some ridiculous shit.
We used to do some fun stuff.
We should fucking do that again before we ever met.
I saw that
and that was like,
these are like some really genuine people.
I'm like,
you guys are cool because I think there's a weird thing that everyone does,
including me who's met,
I've met a lot of people that are on television or a lot of people that are
artists or musicians or actors or comedians or whatever.
It meant a lot of people with varied responses.
So it's like sometimes you meet him and know like you,
like you bummed out that he met him and then sometimes you meet him and you're
like,
wow,
these people are that way too.
Pretty fucking bad ass.
I get kind of squeamish when there's somebody,
I really,
really like it.
I know I'm going to meet them.
Like with Cheryl,
I was like,
Oh God,
like please drink.
Nice.
Fucking awesome.
Yeah.
And sometimes you just have to like,
yeah,
you have to sort of just accept like sometimes the,
the musicians or actors or whatever,
you love their work and then they turn out to be a Douche.
You could still love their work.
It's just,
you know,
you have to separate it,
you know?
Yeah.
And it's not saying that they have to be that way either.
It's just,
it's also saying that
if you meet a guy and they're just extra or a girl and they're just
extraordinarily talented but incredibly troubled,
you've got to realize that this is like a balance going on with human beings.
Yeah.
There's this weird balance and it doesn't always work
gout.
Right.
You know what's interesting though,
I think it's shifting a lot more.
You know,
you get people like Jimmy Fallon who are these like I love Jimmy Fallon.
I think he's a sweetie.
He's creating this realm of like joy,
comedy.
Um,
Bro,
like brilliant shit.
Yeah.
You know,
and,
and like he's got this like great childhood.
Like this is great family.
He loves like,
he seems like a sweet guy too.
Yeah.
There's room for that.
You don't,
you don't have to be fucked up to,
to be an artist anymore,
you know?
And you never really do.
Yeah.
He called Jimmy Fallon and artists.
You got to slow the fucking board style.
Of course.
He's an artist,
a better Neil young impression.
Jimmy Fallon.
He also thinks that he's probably,
I mean it's probably one of the best talk show hosts ever.
He really cares.
You can just tell he's a genuine guy.
Like there's the,
this coming off of him.
Like he seems like a genuinely nice guy.
And so as Jimmy Kimmel,
by the way,
Jimmy Kimmel's a genuinely nice guy.
He's a sweetheart.
Like,
you know,
hurt.
Somebody said something about Jimmy Kimmel was a,
he was a Dick to rob Ford.
You know,
like,
okay,
come on man.
The guy's fucking the Toronto mayor and he smokes crack.
Like if you only have seven minutes with that guy.
I'm sorry,
but we got to get down to pistis.
Yeah.
I can't allow you to fucking talk about your favorite football team for six
minutes and then,
Hey,
what about that crack?
You know,
we gotta get busy right away and if it looks like I'm being a Dick,
I'm so sorry but you smoked crack.
He'll fucking mayor of Toronto Sun.
Oh,
come on.
You got to give up a certain amount of decorum when you're addressing such
issues.
Jimmy Kimmel where he interviewed Jay Leno after the,
well,
you know what man?
Jimmy Kimmel let Jay Leno know what the fuck is up.
That's what he did.
Yes.
Setting to hand it to somebody who's going to like have the balls to go to real
town.
You know
my only problem that is it.
Jay Leno was also being sort of in in a sense enabled or thrust into that
situation by the network because the network,
why would the network change everything around if they didn't want to?
I mean like why are you getting upset?
Like if,
if the cone,
if Conan O'brien went into that position and then all sudden the fucking show
exploded and became this monster mega hit that everybody thought it would be,
then there would be no discussion with Jay Leno to go back and take over the
tonight show.
So then there'd be no discussion about falling back on his word or like,
you know,
what did you say it?
So it was all weird.
It was a in a little bit of a way.
It's weird that's,
it's,
it's the,
when you're dealing with those fucking weird sort of talk show hosts situations,
you know,
you're dealing with those weird,
like the battle between,
you know,
this guy and that guy and they're going to,
who's the best?
And like that these sat talkshow war though the talk show war show with
Letterman and Jay Leno where it shows how Letterman and Jay Leno were like
battling with each other and let them and always wanted to do tonight show late
night.
What was it called?
Late night,
it was called late night and Jay Jay Leno hid in the closet and heard these NBC
executives plotting against him while he was in the closet.
Gay.
Yeah.
So like he knew like what to say to them.
He knew how to fuck with them.
Like to let them know.
So they did like a bug sweep of the room,
try to find the bug.
He was hiding in the closet.
Closets.
Hilarious.
Really.
But it just didn't seem like that's the right way to do it.
You know?
And I,
I liked that what Jimmy Kimmel did was like stand up for another talk show host.
He like,
he say this.
Yeah.
Thinking so I just like it when that happens with public.
I just loved that he decided that it was just something that he wanted to do.
I love that.
You know,
he's so,
it's so strongly like in support of Conan that he decided to like show
solidarity and in his interview with Jay Leno do the word genuine a bunch of
times fucking nucleus of,
of all of this stuff like of the podcasts of your genuine conversations and
you're genuine,
you know,
messages and stuff like that.
Like there's a lot of interesting things happening like Jimmy Fallon,
Jimmy Kimmel.
Yeah.
You get somebody who's not afraid to speak the truth.
That's,
that's really powerful shit.
Well,
Jimmy,
yeah,
you know Jimmy cow,
both of them.
Jimmy Fallon and Jimmy Kimmel Bolt.
I think they get the,
you have the sense that they like it themselves.
Like they're happy with who they are.
They're not,
they're not dissatisfied.
Fuck yeah.
Everybody should for sure.
But like Jimmy Kimmel,
like when I took over the man show with Doug,
Stan hope like he could have been a total dick about that easily.
He could have been rude to get made fun of us and it didn't turn out well.
It turned out to be a disaster.
I didn't know that he had like a bad relationship with the people that were
producing it.
They had like real issues,
legal issues,
like issues over content issues over ownership.
It was like,
oh,
there was a lot of bullshit that went down.
Apparently.
I don't know the,
the,
the real
roots behind it,
but I didn't know that.
I thought these guys just didn't want to do it anymore and now we could do it.
And I didn't talk to them about it,
but he was never a dick about it.
Not even a little bit like,
he's like,
he sent me an email.
It was very friendly about it.
Like the,
the,
the possibility to be a Douche bag was there and he would have been right.
And he chose not to do it.
He would have been right,
but it wasn't,
he wouldn't even been of Douche bag.
It was just make it something that it wasn't,
you know,
and I just,
I,
I've always respected that guy,
but I respected him even more because of that,
because if I was in his position,
I might make fun of me,
you know,
I might be shitted on me.
And when I did his show,
he was like super cool,
like after the fact.
And I like apologize to him for doing a shitty person,
the man show.
And,
but it was,
there was no animosity.
He's just a good guy.
And like you can tell that,
that that's somehow or another,
it gets through the TV,
it gets through the wires,
it reaches you.
You know,
somehow or another,
it gets in there.
And I don't know how much of that you can fake,
you know,
you can fake something.
You can fake a Smidgen,
a smidge here or there,
but a genuine niceness like the Jimmy Fallon exudes,
damn.
I don't know if an asshole knows how to do that,
you know,
I dunno if an asshole knows how to hit that frequency.
Did you guys see the video of them,
uh,
with,
of youtue and Jimmy Fallon on the opening night?
No.
Oh my God.
Listen is one of the most transformative moments of my life over the last year
was falling asleep on the couch.
Um,
you know,
whatever I worked out,
it had something to eat and I was sitting on the couch and a lot of times I
watched like a watch,
like bow hunting shows or watch MMA fights.
I'm a fucking caveman.
If you came over and looked at my DVR,
you feel like,
what the fuck is going on here?
I just like what I like.
Okay.
I'm not judging myself,
but I fell asleep and I woke up and it was the premiere of the Jimmy Fallon,
a first season,
first episode of the tonight show.
And as I woke up,
youtue was singing the acapella version of ordinary love or acoustic version
rather of ordinary love.
And uh,
Jamie pull it,
pull it up.
Is that from the frozen sense to you too on,
ha ha.
No,
listen,
it's a brilliant new song from you too,
but it's not just that.
It's brilliant.
It's one of those moments where,
um,
you're watching in Bano,
you're watching like a,
just a fucking brilliant artists say what you want about that guy,
you know,
say what you want about his political ties and his charitable causes and his
sunglasses indoors at night set.
Which one about that guy,
that guy is a bad motherfucker and whatever it is out there that makes things
great.
Whatever it is.
Where are you watching pink singing while she's spiraling around over an
audience and never losing tune and knowing that it's completely live or whether
it's bano sitting on that fucking couch and youtube behind him playing and Jimmy
Fallon is sitting there and will Smith is sitting there and it's so undeniably
brilliant that I,
I woke up from a nap sitting on the couch to woke up just in time for them to be
joking around and then go into that song like the universe wanted me to see
this.
It's fucking perfect.
It's a perfect moment of entertainment.
It has perfect music.
It has a perfect response.
It has a perfect moment.
Being the premiere of Jimmy Fallon's version of the tonight show.
It has perfect being one of the greatest actors ever will Smith is sitting
there.
I mean a huge fucking movie star.
I mean people don't think he's a bad ass mother fucker.
I've never seen him play Muhammad Ali pay.
The audience is standing up and they're all on their feet screen is,
there's not a guy with a sign stand up,
stand up,
clap,
applaud.
Like if you go to those,
uh,
like if you go to tonight shows shaping at least the old ones they used to have.
A guy would tell you when to applaud.
There's like signs would light up or a guy we're like,
hold up a sign.
That was some beautiful shit.
Right?
That was amazing.
And I love the roots.
You got God damn.
I loved them.
I loved,
I loved the band.
I love Jimmy found,
but I loved that moment.
That moment is that I'll never forget that the sit in them by myself.
Gym Shorts,
still sweaty,
like staring at the TV and it comes on and I'm just like,
God damn.
I just saw something.
I saw fucking shooting star.
I saw an asteroid hit,
I saw some freaky shit.
You know?
I mean that's crazy that an asteroid,
that's only happened once asteroids hit many times.
You know what I mean?
How many fucking,
how many times has there been a,
a big hole slammed into in the earth cause a rock fell from the sky a lot.
How many times is youtube and on the Jimmy Fallon shy?
Once you two was on the Jimmy Fallon show,
one time ever.
And it was the first time.
There's only one first time ever in the whole universe that youtube is going to
be on the Jimmy Fallon show.
That's crazy.
Unless you believe in true infinity.
And then that's the monkey wrench.
Because true infinity means if there is a you,
that the world is what you see.
Everything exists in the exact same form.
Not only once,
but infinitely.
So not only are there so many possibilities in the concept of infinity,
infinity,
meaning infinite possibilities,
we can't even imagine what that means.
What that means is that everything that you've ever experienced,
everything that I've ever experienced you looking exactly like you,
you looking exactly like you,
you with the same creepy do to try to sneak you into the woods.
See fucking large mouth bass,
all that exists in the exact same order and the exact same form in an infinite
number of times.
So that's how crazy infinity is.
Wrap your fucking head around that.
Like wait a second.
So somewhere out there there isn't.
It's not just one right now,
right there.
Not only that,
youtube is playing,
you're not supposed to you.
It's like you too.
I say it like Youtube shouldn't say it that way,
but you right now is probably playing an infinite amount of times all over the
universe and at the exact same moment how the exact same moment,
the exact same words are coming out of the exact same mouth.
That experience everything that has ever happened,
the idea of that never happening again on the other side of the world for sure.
Not In the other side of the world,
but the universe,
the idea of everything that has ever happened,
being unique in comparison to the creation of the world is so preposterous.
The idea that we're so fucking important because we are able to saying capable
of talking,
capable of explaining how important we are,
but the idea that we are any weirder than a black hole or a son.
I mean that's ridiculous.
So the idea of human civilization happening in the exact same order everywhere.
We'd be like,
how is that possible?
But how would it be possible for that?
It'd be other planets that's way crazier and there's a fucking shit ton of
those,
dude.
How would it be possible that there's water in space and there's a lot of it.
In fact,
that's what you seen when you see a comment stupid.
You seen water flying off the back of that thing.
That's water.
That's a fucking earth sized chunk of water flying through space.
Holy Shit.
You know?
Yeah.
The whole thing is nuts.
It's not nuts that you don't exist.
Not just once,
but an infinite amount of times.
That's more likely than a star.
That's more likely then a black hole that's more likely than just the idea of
people breathing air and staying alive and fish sucking air out of water and
some fucking weird contraption called Gills.
That's nuts.
All of it's nuts.
The fact that it exists the same place in the same form all over the universe
and an infinite amount of times and exactly the same order that seems like
likely you think are nuts.
It is.
That's why when you see a moment like you to on the Jimmy Fallon show singing
that song,
like you're witnessing a universal unique moment universal through everything.
Cause the whole thing like that.
That feeling you get when you get goosebumps,
the whole universe got goosebumps for that.
It's interesting that you woke up for it.
It's like you're in tune with that kind of thing.
No,
I got lucky.
I drag a lot of coconut water,
drag it,
some of that delicious sea two oh coconut water.
I probably had a most likely but maybe not.
I mean I'm,
I'm not convinced that reality is real.
I'm not convinced you guys review
in here.
I don't know.
We're not,
what does youtube,
Internet stuff is kind of a approximation of it,
isn't it?
Cause now we can,
we just watched it again and we were experiencing it in a different way.
But that moment has been captured.
That moment can now repeat itself in our liquor controlled medium.
Right?
So it's maybe this is us piecing together all these things that you're talking
about.
I hope if you see it the first time you see it before I said anything about it
to you,
the last thing I want us to flavor that moment with some my own,
uh,
you know,
that's,
I think that was a,
just a tremendous performance.
If somebody sees it and you hear me talking about it,
shut it off and go watch the real thing.
Don't,
you know,
if somebody puts it on youtube,
they might as well be flavors by Joe.
Oh please.
Maybe salt would be better salt and a little Kumon.
It's really good for you.
It's an anti inflammatory.
But you know,
do you guys feel those moments on stage and realize that you're tapping into
something unique when,
when that happens,
when you hit that that,
you know,
we were talking about and we were playing pool.
Like sometimes you just hit this weird stride where everything's just fallen
into place and it feels like automatic and you know that there's that moment.
I'm sure it's,
it's gotta be very similar to the moment like that in comedy with,
with your music.
There's gotta be moments when you guys are just flowing.
You know,
there was a Disney moment,
I don't want to make me feel uncomfortable,
but there was a moment where you were on stage and you were saying in and it was
at the December 21st show,
the 2012 end of the world show and both Joey Diaz and Eddie Bravo came off stage
and they both at the same time go,
that's a bad ass bitch.
That's how bad ass.
But that's a bad ass bitch.
Hey Bravo.
That's a bad ass bitch.
Goddamn.
Those motherfuckers are talented in it.
He's like,
that's a bad ass bitch.
Got,
damn,
those guys are talented.
But it was that moment where,
you know,
you,
it was,
we had never done a show with a musical act before and a lot of my friends were
skeptical.
They were like,
what are you guys gonna do?
Like how's that work together?
How's it work?
So I go,
I think the music probably shouldn't be in the middle cause it would be like,
it would like interrupt the flow of the comedy.
But I think it would enhance the beginning of the comedy.
And I think,
you know,
so we do it this way.
And so when we,
when we did it and you guys got on stage,
it was the first time that Eddie had ever seen you guys live.
And uh,
you know,
he was like,
Holy Shit,
they're good.
Who's like the lyrics,
the fucking,
the music that,
the choices they made.
He just was just like shaking his head.
But I'll never forget that moment where they both walked off stage because they
were both shaking there cause they didn't,
you know,
Joey was going to go on stage next and do some standup.
We got so lucky to be involved with this.
Well,
we're lucky too.
We're all lucky.
We're lucky as shit.
I wouldn't be,
you know,
this,
the show would be completely uninteresting.
It was just me talking every week.
I think you have a lot to say and it's very interesting people,
I heard it,
they've heard it already by now.
I've run out of Shit to say I repeat myself.
I don't even like listening to me anymore,
but we're,
we're all lucky for rails,
you know,
including people listening.
We're all in on this in some fucking weird way.
We're all in on this thing together.
It's just that,
uh,
folks like you and I,
and red van and whoever's on the mic out there,
you're,
you're a part of the lightning rod.
You're part of the lightening Rod that distributes all this shit.
But we're all in it together.
We don't even know what we're doing.
We don't even know why we're doing it.
We just start doing it.
And then somewhere along the line we realized we love it.
And the next thing you know,
he sang songs.
Are you telling jokes or you're fucking making guitars,
whatever it is.
You know,
you find that thing.
Yeah.
CP,
you find that weird weird thing out there in the world.
You know,
whatever it is.
And if you don't,
God damn,
keep looking.
Keep looking.
Rousing kind like go do some browsing myself up.
I don't even know if I'm honest
though.
Questions.
All literature.
It's all fiction.
It's coming from the universe.
Um,
playing on the song.
Yeah,
sure.
I got to like reacclimate myself.
You want to play this on him?
[inaudible] like recently an uplifting one.
But yeah,
no,
you don't have to clean up questions.
If you want to make the folks cry,
maybe we'll have a little yin and Yang peaking the high and low whenever you
want.
I'm going to put some Yang.
Can I make a request?
We may not be able to fulfill it,
but she can put dare you.
How's that?
Not Possible.
Um,
will you put you guys play La River?
I mean,
yeah.
Yeah,
please mess it up.
I fucking love that song.
Sure you want to do it right now.
Okay,
here we go.
Here we go.
I'm going to try something.
That's one of the cool things about music.
You guys can take requests of comedians.
Take requests.
We can play this in a while.
I really try not to mess it up.
Let's just Thunderpussy that.
That kind of request is great.
You don't,
maybe you just play,
okay.
Okay.
What can we do it in?
All right,
I got this.
You Go.
Okay.
Down to the banks of the
but Jane Lane.
Concrete walls on the ELA.
Oh,
new
hall.
Listen to the big city sound.
Huh?
Fall down.
God chains pass.
Chat at town.
MMM.
Okay.
Thing is name.
Hello
me.
Got us a body
mass.
Chan town
man
to the big city
down that trains pass Janet's Dad.
Ah.
Oh Shit.
We got through that one.
Yeah,
that was great.
I love that fucking song.
That was bad.
A house.
Holy Shit.
Is that a tune?
That was really cool.
I liked the banjos making a comeback.
I'd like that.
Huh?
You know,
what about the bands?
What gets thrown under the bus a lot?
What happened?
I have the Banjo.
Gatorade,
you know,
the hillbillies and they,
oh,
those motherfuckers,
you know what?
It's okay.
I like being the underdog.
I'm from Cleveland.
You know,
it's like you're,
you gotta just,
you gotta come back up.
I can banjo respect for drew Carey.
Oh Man.
I met drew Carey.
I met him at,
um,
I met him at swingers,
the diner.
Oh,
okay.
Yeah,
he's there like every day almost.
And great guy.
And I walked up to my house and you know,
I don't normally do this kind of thing,
but I'm a hometown hero lover,
you know?
And I was like true.
My name's Suzanne.
I'm,
I'm from Parma,
Ohio,
which is what the show,
we talked about this on the podcast and she was so fucking nice and he actually
tweeted
out,
I was like,
I threw a tweet at him and he was super cool.
Really Nice Guy.
He's a sweetheart.
He's a genuine nice guy.
Yeah,
it was nice.
Nice.
When you run into people that are genuinely nice,
it's cool,
you know,
and,
and when they're not a fucking,
maybe you caught him on a bad day too.
You can't really do it.
Could be.
We've all been there.
Yeah.
Vol been there.
You guys going to move back to la?
Come on.
I want to,
we just,
we need to make this record and then Nashville Shit.
Dope.
Makes them all cash.
You know what I was thinking though when you were talking about the Banjo,
I remembered about Nashville.
Something that's amazing about Nashville is it has this real wellspring of
music,
which is what'd you just do?
Yeah,
there's a lot of music in Nashville,
right?
But there's a lot of traditional music and like call,
you know,
stuff that's like,
hey,
who do you know?
And not in a bad way like bluegrass music.
I mean it didn't,
it didn't come out of Nashville specifically,
but that region you have traditional music and you're not really in touch with
that many other places.
Like here,
this is a great music scene,
but there aren't people who are like keeping a flame alive
as far as I,
that's interesting.
So they're keeping like a blue grass flame alive.
They really are.
Like American roots music is,
is huge.
And there's people that are dedicated to just like spreading this shit and
making sure people know about it.
Huh.
And that's,
I mean,
that's,
that's why the Banjo is still around.
Do you know,
because someone,
yeah,
I mean there's like,
there's always been a respect that a rock and roll guys pay to things like blue
grass or the blues or did you ever,
you know,
I'm sure you guys know the song.
One of my all time favorite Skinner at songs,
the ballot of Curtis Lowe.
Do you know that song?
It's about,
uh,
him,
picking up bottles and returning,
um,
so you can give money to this Guy Curtis Lowe.
So you sing them a song because this guy would sit out and they'd give them
money,
buy wine with it,
and he would sing songs for people and it's just a fucking beautiful song.
But it's not just a beautiful song.
It's a beautiful song that Skinner did as like,
uh,
just in,
in uh,
in honor of these like unknown blues guys instead of respect for
that are responsible for all of this shit and know it's like you look Jimi
Hendrix,
he did exist without these guys.
I was reading about some guy,
you know,
this is like the recording error in the forties and 50s.
You'd have Wii.
They just zone in on these blues guys.
They find him on the street,
this Guy Blind Willie McTell he was in need and they bring them up to New York
and they cut songs and then give them like 25 bucks it seriously and send it
back and make millions,
millions of dollars and 20 years after it was put out on his records,
this guy,
uh,
like Atlantic records,
this guy amateur it again,
find some on the streets still and he's just doing his thing.
Wow.
Still doing this thing and there's a whole community of these guys,
man.
And whether it was quite a few,
that definitely got taken advantage of for sure.
You know,
and there's all this weird lore behind it all too.
Like I always,
it was,
uh,
fascinated by a Robert Johnson,
you know,
on the whole students.
Yeah.
The crossroads.
He sold his soul to the devil.
The devil would give him better songs.
I mean,
it sounds like they're really good,
but they're really good for the time.
I would think the devil would have like mad at universal magic.
Yeah.
Like there's songs that for whatever reason,
they just don't quite hell hang in there.
They don't quite hold up.
There's some old songs,
so you listened to them.
They're,
they're fascinating but they don't quite touch you,
you know,
and then you get to a certain point where they're like,
okay,
this song will exist forever.
And My,
my register is like songs like whole lot of love,
like Zeppelin,
whole Lotta love.
Like I don't give a fuck what happens.
I don't care if they invent time travel.
I don't care if you've got like robots on Pluto that put your body in suspended
animation and print a three d copy of it.
That breeds carbon dioxide and it wanders around the surface.
When I don't care.
You're not going to make a better song than whole lot of luck.
You might make a different songs.
It might be different,
but it's not going to be better.
It's not possible to be better.
There's something about that.
No,
don't,
don't know.
Down.
There's something about the beauty of palmers voice and the sounds of the guitar
and Jimmy Page is hitting it.
Perfect.
And then the time,
it's the time is marijuana smoke in the air and everyone's on Lsd.
It's just the alone alone don't,
it's just a different time.
Yeah.
They captured this rare moment where the universe gave birth to flowers.
The universe gave birth.
You liked these artistic flowers in the form of human expression.
They were birthed out of the human consciousness and imagination.
Yeah.
They're the pioneers.
You know,
they're the,
they kind of started this thing,
but it's interesting now juxtaposed to like music made today where there's so
many manufactured sounds and stuff.
It's not like,
hey,
this is what the drum sound and my like in my friend's basement,
you know,
fucking awesome.
Seem like the things that are,
I hate the word organic,
but it seems like the right words you use to describe people like the black keys
like that they,
yeah,
they're,
they're awesome.
But they're also still like,
they didn't come up with that sound well,
but you know,
they didn't come up with the blues but he just executed really well.
But Zeplin that's the key.
It's like the Robert Johnson thing.
Pioneers all like that's a great word.
And I also think not a fitting one necessarily.
Maybe ever cause somebody always did it.
Yeah.
Four.
And there was always sensing true.
True.
Yeah.
Isn't that so true?
Isn't that what's unique about the whole thing is it's someone else's.
Oh it will.
There's no real prying ears.
It just,
everyone is sorta handing a torch off and there's this moment where someone
comes up with a whole lot of love and you're like,
wow,
what the fuck is,
you made a pull a black diamond that weighs a thousand pounds.
Yeah.
You figured out a way to make some like universal really
weird and unusual and and,
and,
and important object and they probably weren't even trying to just kind of
filtering this stuff.
It's like a set of circumstances and experiences.
Yeah.
Look it.
These British dudes here,
this music,
they from this weird working class town and when they play,
yeah,
blah,
blah.
Days in there.
Some of them that,
you know,
sometimes you have to step back away from them to realize how great they really
were.
Like if you don't listen to sweet home Alabama for six months and then that's
what you do.
It's like if you don't have sex for like six weeks,
when you,
when you do have sex,
it'll be so amazing because every touch will be like,
the power of the touch will be inflated beyond belief.
Every,
all of it.
The sparks,
the energy,
but the only way for that to build up as you got to take some time off and sweet
home,
Alabama was overplayed to death.
They beat the fuck out of that song because it's so good.
But sometimes you could forget.
You forget how good it is,
what you're saying.
All you need is a little time off.
You need a little time off and you realize that's God trying to speak through
some fat long haired Florida Boys.
That's God speaking to them in between sex,
not having sex for six weeks and then listening and see how,
because
familiarity breeds contempt.
Familiarity breeds contempt.
I,
you know,
sweet Alabama inside and out.
You can't appreciate what it really is.
What it really is is these guys found a lightening rod to the universal
constant.
They just hit that fucking button,
sweet home
Bama
and this is 19 whatever 70 who the fuck knows the cars were all dog shit.
Fucking oil oil crisis is and fucking Nixon and Jimmy Carter.
Everybody's a mess and then all of a sudden he's fat guys out of Florida.
Ugly white trash,
fat guys,
sweet home,
not even fat all the time.
Like in the beginning actually kind of spam.
That's like a joyful song.
He had moments,
right?
They were amazing.
Whatever the fuck they were for that brief moment of time.
You know,
before that plane crash,
they were amazing.
Leonard Skinner.
And to this day,
if I have a like a list of shit on my iPod and I'm like in an airport or
something like that and I'm scrolling through and I see my little Skinner folder
and I'm like,
fuck you gotta go scattered.
Got to go to scattered man.
Fuck in DC.
I feel the same way.
Yeah.
Even if the every song sounds like an ACDC song,
like they don't vary at all.
It doesn't matter.
It's like,
dude,
that's like a chemical rush when you put that stuff.
Yeah.
They're so unique in that it's like,
you know,
dot.
Dot.
You know,
you hear that,
like they have that such a marching sort of style,
you know,
browsing shit.
So many guys come like a into the cage and to mixed martial arts fights.
Yeah.
And even in boxing fight,
it's weightless and ACDC.
Fuck yeah.
Thunder strikes a big one.
We had a really,
uh,
kind of defining moment of our,
of our lifetime,
I would say not lifetime,
but we saw black sabbath.
We were overseas,
we were in Amsterdam and it was a,
ed actually happened to Ben Thanksgiving as well.
Um,
and a friend of ours got us tickets to see black sabbath and you know,
you got to think like,
how much longer does Ozzy?
Yeah.
You know,
you,
you don't want to miss it if you have an opportunity.
And it was amazing.
Like it was really,
you really saw his energy was,
was so genuine.
It really was.
You could tell he was having a blast.
He couldn't sing for shit.
I mean,
he was so off key that he was almost back in key.
Like it was so far off an octave that it was almost back in,
but it was so entertaining to see him because he really felt like,
you felt his energy was like across the whole,
like it was like a,
it was called the zig o dome.
Right.
Was it this huge,
you know,
place.
And it was a,
it was a really crazy experience to see Ozzy Osborne,
you know,
up on stage doing his thing.
He's got his signature moves.
Like between each song it'd be like,
I can't fucking
screaming,
you know.
And it was crazy,
but it was really,
really great to see like,
you know,
he's legendary.
Brian,
you remember when you were with me when one see steel panthers,
right?
Yeah.
Vegas.
We went to see steel panthers in Vegas and the dude who's lead singer does the
most insane
impression of Ozzy Osborne.
I mean pitch movement,
like the way he shuffles on stage.
He does crazy train and it's like,
Holy Shit,
it's so good.
It makes you want to go see Ozzy Osborne.
He really is so good.
Our place that they have right.
Bands like Steel Panther.
Yeah,
it's amazing.
But it makes you want to see somebody else.
Well they have,
um,
they're not just a band.
They were like a show,
you know,
those guys are like a review,
right?
Well it's,
it's,
yeah,
it's almost like a little bit of that,
is this the I'm doing it,
it's hard to tell.
Well,
this audio is hard to hear.
You got when we see it live though,
it's fucking insane.
I mean,
he sounds like Ozzy Osborne in his prime.
exactly.
It's brilliant,
you know?
Wow.
Yeah.
Made you want to go see Ozzy before it's too late.
Who knows how the keys and that Guy Alive,
20 to 30 minute drum solo that went on.
He was being transported.
You were in the 70s you know where they went back and this is what we very
often,
but I did at an Amsterdam and it was,
it was crazy.
It was crazy.
I mean,
you're just like,
fuck yeah,
I'm going to get hired.
Black Sabbath.
Uh Huh.
I remember one time I was right at it.
I was coming home on a plane,
those writing and a lot of times when I write,
I'll eat like a pot edible before I get on the plane.
And this was particularly
strong and for whatever reason I decided to play crazy train over and over and
over again.
I put it on repeat and I played that song for fucking five hours while I was
writing all the way from all the way from New York back to La.
It was five hours of crazy training.
Yeah.
He's just one of those things.
It's like he catch a great,
great groove.
Just fries.
Never thought about writing to other music because we're usually,
I'm writing music,
but that'd be,
you know,
like,
like what does it sound exactly like,
like when I was like,
I could never,
um,
like study when I was in school,
I could never really study if there's music in the background cause I'd be
really distracted by it.
Yeah.
Most of the time I feel the same way,
but I needed comfort.
Yeah.
That's really cool.
It's five hours.
I was too high.
I need it.
That's dedication,
comfort.
But it's also when you get,
when you get super high patterns start to,
once they become like very recognizable by the mind,
the mind settles into this idea that there's not going to be any interruptions
in those patterns.
So like crazy train essentially becomes like a three minute and 35 second ohm
like me because I'm really bad at being hi,
I'm so bad.
I,
I'm not,
it's not,
I lose my sparkle,
you know,
I really can't.
I can't.
Um,
I'm not present.
You know,
I can't really focus on a conversation and I feel very self aware and I want to
take a fucking nap.
I hear her.
I totally understand those things.
They're very,
very logical.
But I think that,
um,
what I like about it is that terrible feeling of everything going completely off
the rails and then you get back to reality.
You take a deep breath and go,
we're okay.
Everything's okay because it gives you,
it gives you such a bizarre Lee introspective perspective and such an intensely
sensitive view of the world that when the ride is over,
like you get off and you go,
okay,
we're fine now.
Okay,
this is helpful.
Like going on a really shitty vacation.
Civil work feels you appreciate your job.
Yeah.
Okay.
Well,
it's not even that it's shitty.
It's just that it's uniquely terrifying moments.
It reveals to you the beauty of just placid reality when everything's just
relaxed.
It's,
see I just get,
I used to smoke all the time and I hit this Rut of massive anxiety and just
sick.
Like I don't really remember like was it like your 23rd and 24th year?
Is that what you said?
Hi for two years.
Pretty crazy.
He was really tough to work with you guys.
I love you.
That was,
those were some times shaped you as a man.
Yeah.
All those journeys,
those cosmic voyages to despair.
Yeah.
Twisty turny roads into the night.
We hear cars start to split it.
You're like,
really?
Yeah.
That's interesting.
It's really the drive for a long time.
I'm going to come to bureau.
What is it?
You know,
it's interesting how the uh,
will prescribe certain,
like Kinda uppers to
people that are hyperactive and it sort of balances that are really fun.
Let me tell you,
I've heard that from several people this week.
It feels like
Adderall recreationally.
Sorry.
I felt like I was on mushrooms.
It was the best thing ever.
Actually.
We were in Paris,
we were in Paris and I,
I took an Adderall and we went to the Eiffel Tower and I had the best time ever.
I felt amazing.
Wow.
You have a super fun and we had a really fun show.
I mean,
do they have consulted a show?
No,
no,
no.
It was way earlier in the day.
I was ready to warn off.
Yeah,
I don't,
I don't like to be Collins.
Is it to wear off?
I don't know,
six hours.
It was fucking awesome.
Second person,
Hannibal Burress said the other day.
It was really fun.
But you know,
I'd say his name wrong all the time.
We've chosen stuff like that.
You definitely like,
you gotta be present,
you know,
you don't want to have to be in control of all of my faculties as much as
possible.
No,
I totally understand.
But something that lasts for six hours,
it seems like fuck boners that lasts for six hours.
What?
We've talked about that too.
All of this problem.
It's crazy.
Did you wear a fanny pack or something to like actually just took one last
night.
So I'm on it right now.
I feel uncomfortable.
I'm amazed that you can feel comfortable ever hear
his breathing.
So you're saying you went out last night or did you just stay home alone
sometimes.
Just to let everybody know what's up.
I got a massage last night,
so I just did it before that.
A massage in quotes,
air quotes,
creeper better.
Listen,
we,
we live in trying times.
[inaudible] just wanted to fuck with the massage.
[inaudible] asshole fucking snake.
Turtle head.
What we need to talk about everything.
That's the problem.
You can't just talk.
Only about passionate people get bored of the same Goddamn for peaches over and
over again.
You brought up the boner anyway.
Listen to [inaudible].
You're welcome
to me.
Boners do you know in the comments,
is it like,
does it give you like a whisper?
You hear like whistling
the demon boners on its way between the worlds opens up just to creek
or spirits come flying through your fucking nervous system.
He feel them.
Yeah.
I had an interesting conversation with this girl
wants to choose talking about like,
uh,
um,
like the difference between a woman getting excited and a man getting excited is
that it's pretty obvious if a man's excited,
but like a woman can be a prostitute and she could totally pretend to be excited
and not give a fuck.
But a man has like this one thing that he has to show that.
So if he's like acting excited,
but he doesn't have an erection though,
like,
Hey,
what do you do?
You being deceptive flyer.
What's going on here?
Who are full of Shit?
It's like,
it's interesting how nature said that up.
It's way easier to lie the dudes.
It's also way easier to lie to dudes,
right?
I mean,
God,
we're totally getting down.
But like if you're,
if you're not wet,
you're not wet.
And that's,
that's gotta be disappointing for a dude.
But that's,
I mean,
come on a little bit.
Turn fingers.
We don't know any better.
We're retarded.
Apparently not.
I could convince myself otherwise.
Men are retarded.
We,
it's easy for us to care.
You know,
she's not June,
but she wasn't wet,
but it was,
she's so horny
pill.
This doesn't,
you know,
she's probably going to get off and go organic.
Probably gluten free.
Make a difference.
I'm sure it does.
Birth control and not on birth control.
What I'm saying is you fuck,
um,
I bet it does.
Zane,
you have better orgasms.
Like the whole thing.
It's like you off of it come out from this.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
I'm sure it's,
it's like a muted sexual side to yourself.
I'm sure.
I mean it to get bigger and that's fun.
It's letting your body thinks that it's pregnant.
Yeah.
It's really weird is it's letting your body thinks it's pregnant.
I um,
I don't think I would ever go back on anything like that.
It's crazy.
Probably not the smartest thing for your body.
Right.
But it helps people in some things like girls who have acne,
a lot of times we'll get on and actually gave me acne.
Whoa.
Yeah.
It was a real bummer.
It's interesting still also that they've never figured out a solution like that
for men,
like a pill solution.
And I wonder if it has drive that same sort of compromising aspects like,
well,
there's accutane if you want the hard stuff,
but that's pretty we we're talking about is this
something that keeps me then north can make cement sterile sterilize.
Yeah.
That's a horrible thought.
Isn't it?
Like a temporary sterile listened to what you just said.
That's a horrible thought.
But the pill is reversible,
is it not?
And apparently it's like a walk in procedure.
It's 100% reversible.
Oh.
I think sometimes they can.
You know what I mean?
You have to go to a really good doctor that knows what they're doing,
but I think there are definitely can be complications whenever you start cutting
and stitching.
It is unfortunate that all of the pressure lies on the woman.
It is.
And you read it.
You just kind of reveal it like that.
Now the think about it,
it is,
it's horrifying to me to think of fucking with the testicles,
but at the same time it's totally routine to be honest.
Yeah.
Notice that you get an Iud,
that shit is fucked up.
Going into shock.
Yeah.
I went into shock.
Like I literally,
um,
you know,
had like,
it's,
it's called [inaudible] are vague.
I don't know how to describe,
I can't remember the actual African dilation.
You,
you,
um,
your body doesn't reject
this repeating words I've heard online.
It's closed.
There's a word for it.
I mean,
I know I rode
purchase.
Great.
That's really funny.
I'm sorry.
I'm talking about
because you've got a robot fucking inserted into your vagina.
Come you up with Liddy words.
Sorry.
I feel better.
It's okay.
I can,
you know,
hang with the boys.
It certainly is like rude not just of us,
but of culture to sort of make that distinction.
Like it would be disgusting for a guy to take a pill that makes you sterile,
like kills your sperm.
You'd be like turned off by that.
They didn't just didn't put it on the market.
I think there's a certain,
a valuable asset sort of mindset that goes along with the idea of fertility.
And I think that virility and fertility are very important to men.
And the idea of killing all your sperm ease with a pill seems scary.
Yeah.
You know,
if you're really going to totally commend,
you would get an operation.
If you weren't going to totally commit the idea of cooking them with some sort
of an evil compound,
you just freeze that fine.
Yeah,
but I can't come out the same way.
It's like vegetables probably.
Would you cook with frozen bins?
It's like drinking VA.
Would you rather cook with frozen vegetables?
Not necessarily.
Yeah.
Something's wrong.
They're just wrong.
We don't know what it is.
I totally get it.
If I was a check,
I'd be really bummed out if somebody wanted me to take a pill that made my body
thinks that it's pregnant.
Yeah.
And then also kills your libido,
which is probably a little of nature would do like almost automatically if
you're pregnant,
probably like chuck.
Okay.
Slow down hooker,
slow down.
You don't need any more deck.
You got a baby on the way and take it down a notch.
Some.
It's an interesting,
like when you go through your relationships,
like obviously if you're dating,
it's not as much of a problem,
you know,
because he used condoms and that's fine.
Honestly like,
but,
but if you're really serious with somebody and then you get to that point where
you're like,
you know,
I love you.
I don't want to use this anymore.
Let's look,
let's kick it up a notch.
Right.
You know,
it is a,
then you get to that point where like you,
you have to figure out,
well shit,
how do I want to manipulate my body to have more pleasurable sex or,
or more intimate connection if you will?
And,
or,
you know,
um,
let's just,
uh,
let's have a,
you know,
risk that we're going to take and it may or may not make a baby.
That's fucking terrifying.
Yeah.
The idea may or may make a person
as a fucking tricky thing,
especially when you're young musicians trying to travel the road and yeah.
I don't want to get anybody pregnant on the road though.
Be What would happen if you had a bit visit your baby daddy and Tennessee got
some guy pregnant Tennessee magic chicks could get guys pregnant.
Boy dudes would be such prudes it'd be hilarious.
Have girls,
he'd get us pregnant like fucking me over guys who built it would be a total
role reversal of jerk off.
I'll just fucking jerk off.
Okay,
fine over here.
Just jerking off.
I don't need anybody to get me pregnant.
We we'd just get tons of abortions would be like the,
like I,
everyone would be getting a board every day.
But what if you were a dude who had this like weird sort of genetic desire to
breed?
You know what if you were like,
you had all these male aggressive qualities that we associate with being male
but also the need to get pregnant,
like the universe hit a switch on.
You nurture this weirder shit when it comes to like fucking frogs.
I can switch sex and we weird fucking bugs.
Some people love to get pregnant just to say that they're pregnant.
I'm not kidding.
It's really fucking weird.
You meet a lot of people out there,
you know?
And it's just like
really me getting pregnant just to say they're pregnant.
What do you think they,
maybe they're not getting pregnant,
but,
but sometimes the,
I enjoy the most,
like in a cup,
the Smith portion,
right?
Well,
it definitely gets you.
Okay.
Installations almost immediate.
Well,
I definitely feel like it can be,
let me rephrase that because God,
you know,
go for it everybody,
if you want to get down,
procreate,
like more power to you,
but you have to admit you've seen people exploit it.
Yes.
In a way that it's like,
like,
do you really want to have this,
this life that you're creating?
Or do you just love like your Facebook updates?
And you know what I mean?
Like there's,
there's an interesting aspect.
Like I think it's,
it's,
um,
someone in,
in someone I know posted a photo of the pregnancy test right on the Facebook.
It was like,
you peed on that
fucked up.
You know,
I think,
um,
as a person who's never given birth,
your perspective would radically change.
If you,
that's true,
and I've never been pregnant side of you,
but it's also like what people choose to and not to share on Facebook.
Right.
You know that gets real squirrely.
Like you're like sometimes like you go on someone's Facebook and like,
especially if it's someone they know and they write like a bunch of like really
personal shit about a relationship or something and you're like,
yeah,
I'm a,
I'm going to walk away from it.
It's like I don't want to certainly not going to comment.
Yeah,
you go girl.
You know,
good things come to those who wait or some fucking Maxwell house,
coffee,
commercial,
whatever,
you know,
Blah Blah Blah.
Sorry to hear you're fucking,
you're in the dumps.
Like,
like why is,
why are people like Brian and stuff like Ben,
the
guy who was like,
he was like,
like,
that's it.
I'm done.
Like I'm on.
You reach out to him because you're a good man.
Ben had somebody,
you captured it.
I think people are fucking lonely and that is an outlet that everyone has access
to,
you know?
So nobody's going to listen to them in real life so they can put it out there
and maybe someone will listen to them digitally.
It's a powerful and yet terrifying thing sometimes because then you get people
that are fucking annoying and then people that are really serious in a dark way
or you know,
it's,
it's such a weird balance.
I can never tell how I feel about it because social media is great for a band
like us because that's how you stay afloat,
you know?
That's how you stay present.
Cause we're not assigned van,
we're not on the radio,
but at the same time then there's like then your personal circle,
your personal friends and that's some crazy shit.
You know,
sometimes you just get these people that like they,
they want to reveal these really personal things and I never know what to do.
I,
you know,
I just block that shit.
I who gets,
it can be off putting,
but it's also important to,
for people to be able to get shit out,
right?
Yeah.
I was listening to something and they're talking to journal,
these mental health
people,
man talk in people's,
definitely the best
mental health workers in Africa.
Right.
And they were,
they were over there and all these African tribes,
people are more native.
People were kind of rejecting these mental health workers cause they'd come in
and uh,
the,
these people,
the more,
uh,
these African people would say,
well they come in here and they don't say anything about dancing.
They don't say anything about putting it out for the community and say anything
about turning these feelings.
Uh,
you know,
uh,
depersonalizing them as evil spirits.
They just tell us to come into a room with a stranger,
a dark room with a stranger,
talk about their problems,
you know,
Tech Talk Therapy,
Huh.
Instead of,
and they'd say,
we don't want this kind of western feel.
We want to just get it out and do it together and dance and hang.
You know,
and I'm not saying Facebook is really doing that,
but there's a certain similarity there between like mid shared.
It's all right.
Well it is eventually I think right sharing though.
Well,
this is excessive sharing and it's also like,
it's all about like the,
the,
the comfort that people have in discussing like very personal relationship stuff
with or very personal,
uh,
you know,
more bid thoughts or worries about your own finite life or whatever it is that
you like.
Sometimes you read someone's Facebook page and want to know whether or not
you should reach out to them.
Read some like weird moody thing that they wrote and you go,
Whoa,
like what the fuck is he saying here?
Like what is this some shit that I'm going to read and then wish that I called
him when I hear that something went wrong.
You know,
we all worry about that kind of stuff.
But I think that
what we're doing by connecting with each other on like things like Twitter and
then things like Facebook and then ultimately whatever the new ones are that
keep coming,
cause it seems like their network and it's never going to stop.
They're going to get deep.
This oculus rift,
Facebook connection,
who knows where the hell that's going to lead with that.
That could lead to some insane place.
I mean,
Oculus Rift,
if you've never put it on before,
Dunkin has one of these things.
He slapped the helmet on,
maybe he'll let you use it.
It's amazing.
And right now it's,
it's an instance.
I don't,
I don't know anything about it.
Oh,
how dare you teach.
Oculus rift is a new version of virtual reality that they're developing games
for and they have a few demos right now and they're making some new games.
But most of what you're getting when you look at the tech these days is
essentially samples of what's potentially possible a door into whatever this is.
That's so intoxicating that Facebook,
how much they paid for it or thinking it was $300 300 bucks.
If it's just hard.
It's just a Dev kit right now.
So like right now it's running on,
I mean how much it Facebook 2 billion.
I thought you'd being silly,
like $300 I'm like,
damn,
I wish I'd known.
I would give him for shit.
But what?
2 billion?
Hello?
That's how crazy.
This technology as you put this headset on and you like look around and you see
the sky,
you see leaves falling from the trees.
You see birds flying around three dimensional environment.
Yeah,
and they have this a one you interact with it.
You can walk around in it right now you can't interact with it,
but unquestionably it's calming.
I want to wear your helmet.
Yeah,
no,
won't.
He'll let you do both.
You should shouldn't be specify which one you liked first or whether or not
together because that would be fucking crazy.
With the helmet on,
you'd be like,
what am I feeling?
But what am I saying?
They really leaves falling when someone's fucking me in the ass.
They really got to figure it out though because it's still makes a lot of people
sick and you know,
every time I let people use it,
they were like,
most of them are like,
no,
this is,
I can't,
I have to sit down.
I tried it.
It didn't make me sick.
I think it's the universe trying to weed out weak bitches.
I just get you to do the roller coaster one.
No,
I'm just kidding.
I did.
The one I did was so mild.
I'm completely kidding,
because all I did was walk around in the backyard.
It didn't make me sick,
but I have her,
I get sick when I read my laptop in the back of a car,
like if I'm in the backseat and someone else's driving,
I try to read my laptop,
like call of duty,
like three,
like three 60 video games.
I can't do that yet.
It's like watching the Blair witch project.
I don't,
I don't play them because I get addicted to games.
I have a issue.
Seriously.
Peeky peeky I got a little bit of nothing,
a little crazy
call of duty.
He'll just makes you pukey.
He's Super Geeky.
Oh,
I hear myself slurring and I want to stop talking now.
So goodbye.
Listen,
I'm,
I think we're out of time.
We're going to turn into a it any second now,
but it was always awesome hanging out with you guys.
I love you guys.
You're the shit.
You're such positive.
Awesome,
fun people to be around at where I can speak for Brian.
We're honored.
Yeah,
yeah.
I'm sorry.
I'm speaking for you,
Brian.
Speak for yourself,
bitch.
I love you guys.
You said it.
He means it to,
he tells me when you're not around.
Uh,
thanks to our podcast sponsors.
Thanks to a Goddamn it,
why don't I have a mini study?
I know what it is.
I just don't know what their code is.
Ooh,
Masa t give them all the same,
hold on,
I'll find out Lumosity.
I won't leave you hanging you freaks.
Cause I love your,
I think you just say the website Joe sent you.
There's,
when you're signing up,
there's a place to actually choose how it's actually wrong.
Again,
Brian,
it's lumosity.com/joe so go to Lou masi.com/joe and click the start training
button and start playing your first game Lumosity.
It's a bunch of cool games designed to increase your brain's ability to function
faster because of exercise.
The idea is it's a gym for your mind and what I said there,
your brain's ability to function factor faster.
Take into account that I am certainly not a scientist by any stretch of the
imagination,
nor do I know if those games really,
truly,
I've read studies that they say that games,
video games especially enhance cognitive function in some strange way.
What the fuck do I know though,
folks?
Huh?
I might there while they're doing these tests,
huh?
What I'm saying is Lumosity is fun and accomplishes a lot of the things that
they've attributed to a video games.
And you can even design games specifically for the shit that you're interested
in.
And I'm giving Lumosity a full commercial because I'm not sure if we did it the
first time to go sort of eliminated by accidental Mack explosion.
Anyway,
lumosity.com forward slash Joe,
I will see you guys on Friday with the Great Dennis Mckenna.
Dennis's bringing in a,
a good friend of his and a,
we're going to have a crazy podcast that it's most likely going to blow your
fucking mind.
So tune in Ben as well.
And uh,
I will see you guys,
uh,
April 3rd in Miami at the Fillmore theater with the Great Tony Hinchcliffe.
And,
uh,
the other two dates,
Baltimore on April 25th in Orlando on April 18 fault.
Those dates are almost sold out,
so hop on it freaks.
All right,
much love.
See you soon.
Pick kiss honey.
Honey,
honey,
honey ban on Twitter.
Holla.